sogar einmal im südsudan und auf der
anderen seite auch im mittelmeer und es
wird dann am späteren abend gehen um die
einrichtungs bezogene impfpflicht da
gibt es anträge aus der afg und auch aus
der unionsfraktion und um den
sogenannten genesenen status so lange
müssen sie natürlich nicht warten wir
besprechen das thema nämlich jetzt schon
gleich und ich freue mich dass da ist
heike behrens die gesundheitspolitische
sprecherin der spd-fraktion und die
größe herzlich kino sorge aus der
unionsfraktion auch da ist
gesundheitspolitischer sprecher wir
werden natürlich nicht umhinkommen einen
blick zu werfen auf die beschlüsse die
gestern in der bund länder runde gefasst
worden sind es soll lockerungen geben
das haben wir eben im beitrag wenn man
auch schon gesehen welche punkte ist da
um welche punkte ist im einzelnen geht
aber gucken wir vielleicht noch mal auf
ihre persönliche bewertung dieser
beschlüsse gestern frau behrens was ist
ihrer einschätzung
dass die modellierer vorhergesagt haben
nämlich das mitte februar im grunde der
höhepunkt der pandemie wohl erreicht
sein wird dass sich das erfüllt hat und
wir jetzt einfach die chance haben auch
erst eröffnungs schritte zu machen und
ich finde da ist gestern maßvoll
entschieden worden indem man eben diese
drei stufen sich vorgenommen hat ich
glaube das ist verantwortbar was da
beschlossen worden ist muss man glaube
ich sagen die pandemie bezüglich und
bezogen auf die omikron welle nämlich
wie das im laufe des jahres weiter geht
kann kann auch der beste modell ihrer im
moment nicht vorhersagen herr sorge was
ist ihre einschätzung der beschlüsse von
gestern also mein eindruck ist auch dass
das in die richtige richtung geht ich
hätte mir zwar gewünscht dass wir über
öffnungs schritte auch über konkrete
dinge schon viel früher gesprochen
hätten wir müssen jetzt schauen dass
eben auch die relativ geäußerten dinge
in diesen beschluss dann auch umgesetzt
werden sie haben sie angesprochen das
thema genesenen status ist noch offen
das thema einrichtungs bezogen im
pflicht ist noch offen und vor allen
dingen das kommunikationsdesaster was
war hatten mit dem rk ii das muss
aufgeklärt werden und die impfpflicht
die allgemeine sollen und ich besprochen
da kommen wir aber gleich noch mal drauf
ich wollte dann nochmal gucken auf das
was gestern beschlossen worden ist
biologen und mediziner sagen es ist ein
bisschen gewagt so konkrete zahlen auch
zu setzen weil
egal wie präzise die modellierer bislang
auch gewesen sind sie haben es ja eben
gesagt wirklich wissen tut man nicht wie
die lage im am zwanzigsten märz ist ja
ich glaube wir müssen jetzt sorgsam
darauf achten dass dieses frühlings
erwachen was wir jetzt sozusagen ein
bisschen intonieren dass das nicht zu
einem bösen erwachen wird und das
erfordert eben wirklich dass alle
miteinander weiter sehr aufmerksam sind
wir in der politik müssen sehr sorgsam
beobachten wie es jetzt tatsächlich die
weitere infektions lage wie ist die
entwicklung in unseren krankenhäusern
vor allem wir wissen auch noch nicht ob
die mikrowelle nicht erst noch bei den
älteren in der bevölkerung ankommt das
würde natürlich noch mal echte
rückschläge bedeuten das muss alles sehr
sorgsam beobachtet werden und ich glaube
die botschaft von gestern muss auch sein
dass alle bürgerinnen und bürger weiter
sehr aufmerksam sein müssen also
kontakte weiterhin begrenzt halten
masken tragen wo immer möglich die
abstandsgebot einhalten das erfordert
schon weiter ziemlich viel disziplin von
uns allen ist die frage ob das eher
sorge überhaupt noch funktioniert nach
den beschlüssen von gestern denn die
signale werden ja größtenteils dann so
gewertet werden wir sind über den berg
also muss ich auch nicht mehr so
aufpassen sie haben gesagt man hätte die
öffnungs debatte sogar schon viel früher
führen müssen auch dass es nicht so ganz
allgemeiner konsens und dann kommt aus
einzelnen richtungen immer was denken
sie wie riskant ist es jetzt nach diesen
beschlüssen oder wie fahrlässig werden
die leute jetzt sein der kunde muss man
ja froh sein dass diese panik prognosen
die ja auch von
bundesgesundheitsminister in den letzten
wochen immer wieder erzeugt wurden sind
sich so nicht bewahrheitet haben und
deshalb glaube ich ist es jetzt ganz
wichtig mit einer gewissen vorlaufzeit
auch zu sagen ja wir können optimistisch
in die zukunft gehen wir können auch
öffnungen marken oder wir müssen jetzt
grundsätzlich die debatte führen was
nach dem 19 märz passiert weil alle
maßnahmen auf die grundlage der maßnahme
nach dem infektionsschutzgesetz würden
dann auslaufen es sei denn der bundestag
verlängert diese grundlage und da müssen
wir jetzt auch sehr grundsätzlich
sprechen weil selbst in der
ampelkoalition fdp beispielsweise ja
sagt wir brauchen diese maßnahmen
eigentlich gar nicht mehr und ich bin
immer der meinung dass wir eher
begründen müssen warum maßnahmen noch in
kraft sein sollen anstatt zu sagen ja
das ist halt irgendwie moderat ist als
ziemlich bequem dass man diese grundlage
hat sondern die bundesregierung das ist
ja auch in diesem beschluss klar
geworden ist jetzt aufgefordert
entsprechend neue regelung vor zu sehen
wie es nach dem 97 weitergehen soll und
das erwartet er auch habe ich nicht
verstanden was sie denn eigentlich
wollen oder sie haben von panik
prognosen ihm zu sagen mal mit karl
lauterbach gesprochen der hat aber mit
seiner prognose eigentlich recht ja
relativ präzise sogar was auch was die
tage angeht nämlich dass die mikrowelle
jetzt gebrochen ist an dieser stelle was
sich bei jetzt aus ihrer antwort nicht
raus gehört haben wollen sie jetzt dass
bestimmte instrumente weiter bestehen
auch über den zwanzigsten märz hinaus
müsste dann im infektionsschutzgesetz
werden oder sagen sie es kann jetzt doch
alles weg da müssen sie sich erstmal
festlegen bei der eine punkt ist dass
das was jetzt passiert ja kein geheimnis
war das waren die modellierung von einem
experten die gesagt haben omikron ganz
neue rahmenbedingungen viele milde
verläuft aber auch sehr viele neue
infektionen und gleichzeitig ab mitte
februar ein sehr starkes abflachen an
dieser kurve und da hätte ich mir
gewünscht das war ja auch die
aufforderung auch aus den ländern schon
viel früher diese öffnung szenarien
durchzuspielen wir haben die diskussion
momentan im handel wir haben die
diskussion in der gastronomie die sagen
das kommt jetzt zum richtigen zeitpunkt
aber teilweise eben noch gefällig
unkonkret und deshalb noch mal der punkt
auch der frage der öffnung also
maßnahmen müssen die form das müssen wir
jetzt führen die debatte und dazu muss
wahrscheinlich auch neue gesetzliche
regelung geben jetzt muss ich ihn noch
mal um entschuldigung sie kommen gleich
doppelt deswegen weil er mir das nicht
beantwortet hat was soll was sollte drin
sein in diesem viel zitierten
instrumentenkasten nach dem zwanzigsten
märz im infektionsschutzgesetz ihrer
meinung nach das muss eine grundlage für
die länder geben heute so konkret einem
eine art basisschutz also dass die
länder die möglichkeit haben sofern
gefährliche varianten auftreten sollten
schnell wieder zu reagieren das ist die
frage ob wir diesen instrumentenkasten
so wie er momentan auch unter data
gesichtspunkten auf den weg gebracht
worden ist in der form brauchen obwohl
das nachjustieren müssen und das ist ja
auch in den beschluss aufgeführt das
also begrüßte dass die bundesregierung
jetzt dabei ist auch diese überarbeitung
des infektionsschutzgesetzes auf den weg
zu bringen und das werden wir im märz
dann im plenum entsprechend auch
debattieren müssen dass ich mal gucken
ob ich sie konkret zu konkreten aussagen
während er hat ja nur basisschutz gesagt
das ist was die meisten unter masken
verstehen beziehungsweise die meisten
verstehen nur masken darunter andere
sagen zum basisschutz gehört auch ich
glaube franziska giffey hat sich gestern
abend gestern am späten nachmittag
ähnlich geäußert gehören auch tests
beispielsweise
und die anscheins nicht und und
tatsächlich auch kontakt beschränkung
was ist ihre sicht ja also die
regelungen die wir im 28 absatz 7 bisher
haben dass infektionen
infektionsschutzgesetz genau das sind im
grunde diese basis schutzmaßnahmen die
auch die länder jetzt zu recht erneut
einfordern sie sagen wir brauchen weiter
dieses instrumentarium um dort wo es
gegebenenfalls ein besonderes
ausbruchsgeschehen gibt um dort auch
reagieren zu können und ich bin der
festen überzeugung dass das richtig ist
denn es sind möglichkeiten da werden
optionen zur verfügung gestellt die die
länder je nach bedarf tatsächlich
greifen können oder eben auch nicht
greifen können das ist angemessenes
handeln in der pandemie dieses brauchen
wir und dazu müssen wir so hat herr
sorge schon recht dieses
infektionsschutzgesetz ändern aber ich
will schon noch einen aspekt anfügen da
ist nicht nur die koalition gefragt sie
haben mir einmal gesagt sie wollen eine
konstruktive opposition sein und beim
infektionsschutzgesetz geht es schon
darum die voraussetzungen zu schaffen
dass die bundesländer handlungsfähig
sind und das ist eine solche eine
gemeinsame verantwortung dieses
parlamentes sein und vor allem auch im
zusammenwirken wirklich von bund und
ländern da hat er ja nicht wenige
unions-ministerpräsidenten quasi im
nacken der wird er so viele
möglichkeiten glaube ich dann gar nicht
haben auch hier im bundestag aber ich
will consumer auf den hauptpunkten auf
dem sie eben angesprochen haben das was
sie gesagt haben was in was noch nötig
sein wird fordern auch die grünen ich
habe irene mihalic im laufe der woche
dazu gesehen gelesen und gehört die fdp
sieht das ein klein wenig anders denn es
ist ja nur hat beispielsweise am
dienstag vor der fraktionssitzung gesagt
im grunde müssen wir alles erst mal
streichen weil wir handlungsfähig sind
und notfalls schnell auch bestimmte
sachen wieder installieren können also
wie viel diskussionen wird es an dieser
stelle wenn der koalitions dazu noch
geben dazu gibt es mit sicherheit
intensive diskussion und umso wichtiger
war es dass gestern die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz gemeinsam
mit dem bundeskanzler hier klar diese
punkte eingefordert haben das wird uns
wahrscheinlich schon ein bisschen
rückenwind geben auch in den beratungen
mit der fdp und ich will an der stelle
durchaus auch ein bisschen deutlicher
werden ich erwarte tatsächlich hier von
dem kleinsten koalitionspartner auch
dass er sich wirklich in das gemeinsame
anliegen der pandemie bekämpfung und
pandemie bewältigung stellt und dazu
gehört es auch dass man den ländern das
notwendige instrumentarium zur verfügung
stellt damit sie die schutzmaßnahmen
ergreifen können die gegebenenfalls
notwendig sind denn es ist tatsächlich
es werden möglichkeiten zur verfügung
gestellt und nicht dinge festgeschrieben
die bekämpfung der pandemie ist
weiterhin das stichwort herr sorge wird
es eine allgemeine impfpflicht geben in
absehbarer zeit aber mir hat sich dafür
wir haben als union ein antrag
unterbreitet er gern ich meine frage die
frist für eine allgemeine impfpflicht
ich will sind ja gerade erklären wir
haben diesen antrag deshalb auch
unterbreitet weil wir sehen dass es ein
sehr breites meinungsspektrum gibt bei
der frage allgemeine helmpflicht ist ja
schon fraglich was heißt denn allgemeine
impfpflicht und deshalb haben wir gesagt
wir brauchen eine impfpflicht für den
fall gefährlicher varianten ich halte es
für falsch zu sagen wir beschließen eine
impfpflicht für alle auf vorrat für eine
variante die wir nicht kennen mit
impfstoffen die im herbst überhaupt noch
nicht absehbar sind und zum schluss
gruppen nicht definieren wo wir wissen
da gibt es eine statistisch hohes risiko
und deshalb haben wir ein sehr
ausgewogenen entwurf vorgelegt und sind
also nicht d'accord mit dem antrag so
alle einfach mal pauschal impfen lassen
zu wollen wir müssen sprache präzise
sein das was die union vorgelegt hat ist
ein antrag das was diverse gruppen
kollegen werden und wo er jetzt auch die
die gruppe um 10 man was vorgelegten
gesetzentwürfe ich habe schon gesehen
sie sind gar nicht einverstanden mit dem
was er gerade gesagt hat nein es ist ja
leider auch sehr missverständlich was er
hier vor trägt weil die union hat ihren
antrag überschrieben mit dem vorsorge
wer aber im vorsorge betreiben will der
muss jetzt im grunde den schritt gehen
damit im herbst vorgesorgt ist das heißt
denn wir haben
nein herr sorge wir haben die situation
dass eigentlich ganz gut zu dem wesen
und dann haben sie das eben so ist von
anfang bis ende gewesen sie habe präzise
darauf eingehen wer mehr ebenfalls einen
die mundschutz haben möchte der muss im
grunde das impfschema durchlaufen haben
und das sind eben nach heutigem
wissensstand drei impfungen und für
diese drei impfungen braucht man vier
monate
das heißt wenn wir im herbst geimpft
ankommen wollen dann müssen wir die
menschen zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
auffordern lasst euch impfen damit wir
echte vorsorge betreiben können und das
ist doch unser anliegen wir wollen kein
wir wollen vor die nächste welle kommen
wir wollen verhindern dass wenn wir
durch irgendeine virusvarianten wieder
überrascht werden dass wir wirklich den
immunschutz innerhalb der bevölkerung
auf einem stand über diesen menschen
nicht mehr schwer erkrankten und wo eben
auch todesfälle verhindert werden und
wer vorsorge treiben möchte der sollte
sich jetzt dafür einsetzen eine
impfpflicht für alle erwachsenen york
legt voranzutreiben und im übrigen herr
sorge ich glaube wir hätten ein paar
punkten durchaus anknüpfungspunkte
zwischen ihrem antrag und unseren
gesetzentwurf und darüber sollten wir
dann vielleicht in kürze mal ins
gespräch kommen damit wir am ende eine
breite mehrheit für echte vorsorge in
der pandemie bekommen gerne direkt dazu
also dieses mit jubel frau kollegin dass
das grenzt ein bisschen ein politisches
kabarett also jetzt zu sagen in dem
moment wo sie mitbekommen sie bekommen
keine mehrheit nicht mehr innerhalb der
eigenen koalition haben sie eine
mehrheit für den antrag zu einer
allgemeinen pflicht und jetzt so zu tun
als wenn die opposition den nicht
zustimme seit das nicht konstruktiv wir
haben ganz konstruktiv gesagt wir
brauchen im vorsorge mechanismus und
jetzt auch zusagen für den herbst also
die jetzige impfpflicht die sie fordern
bringt für diese welle gar nichts mehr
für den herbst können sie nicht
definieren inwieweit überhaupt diese
impfpflicht für alle nutzen hat wir
wissen impfen schützt ich bin auch ein
befürworter des impfens aber eben die
frage des wie ist ein ganz anderer sie
sagen sie wollen einfach mal alle durch
impfen ab 18 weil sie glauben im herbst
bei irgendeiner variante hätte das einen
effekt wir wissen aber dass wir auch
unter verfassungsrechtlichen
gesichtspunkten da sehr genau
differenzieren müssen da stellt sich die
frage ist dieses ziel überhaupt geeignet
wir wissen impfstoffe die momentan
bestehen wirken für varianten die im
herbst möglicherweise grassieren gar
nicht richtig wir wissen nicht wie lange
sie wirken und dann die leute zum impfen
zu verpflichten in dem wissen dass man
möglicherweise alle zwei drei monate
sich pusterla suchen sie geben ein nein
ich habe
einfach
auf ihre äußerung versorger sollten wir
versuchen noch unterzukriegen dann ist
es auch fast schon neun deswegen eine
frau bei uns nochmal direkt auch dazu ja
ich meine er vermittelt ich weiß nicht
noch immer nicht genau wo er persönlich
steht aber ich will noch einmal deutlich
machen das was wir vorgelegt haben ist
ein interfraktioneller gruppenantrag und
kein fraktionsantrag dieser
gruppenantrag hat zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
schon über 200 unterschriften aus
unterschiedlichen fraktionen das ist die
stärke unseres vorgehens weil wir ja ein
gruppen verfahren haben und damit auch
ich schon dass die union im grunde nur
so pauschal sich davon abgrenzt und sich
auf dieses verfahren auch gar nicht
einlässt antrag den sie im einbringen
demnächst schließt ja auch nicht aus
dass ich tatsächlich abgeordnete der
unionsfraktion zu dem einen oder anderen
gruppenantrag positionieren ist mir
aufgefallen bei der vorbereitung gibt es
überlegungen wie es geht ich glaube es
gibt einige unions-abgeordnete die sich
auf deren antrag von herrn kubicki stuhl
stürzen ist übertrieben aber dabei denn
er war für den mit stimmen da könnte man
ja genauso gut sagen irgendwie wird es
auch abgeordnete aus union geben die den
antrag den anderen gruppen antrag mit
unterstützen also erstens wir haben
diesen antrag den unions an die marie
entwurf ich muss präziser sein wir haben
den unionsantrag wo wir ja auch genau
definieren in welche richtung das gehen
soll in der fraktion mit großer mehrheit
beschlossen das heißt wir sind auch
insofern eine der größten gruppen sie
wollten dass gruppen antragsverfahren
und jetzt werden wir sehen in den
abstimmung wie die abstimmung läuft um
letztendlich muss man auch sagen dass
die allgemeine impfpflicht so kommt ist
unwahrscheinlich
ich muss aufhören weil die
bundestagspräsidentin an ihrem platz
angekommen ist und kino sorge hatte
recht warum gestern getwittert einmal
hin und her und hat geschrieben
irgendwie eigentlich sollten vielleicht
doch ruhig um 38 anfangen weil ich
geschrieben habe ich habe so viel zettel
und soviel stichwort auf dem zettel in
der tat wir helfen aber so einfach ist
es dann halt auch nicht vielen dank dass
sie heute morgen bei uns gewesen sind
hier sorge auch ihren frau bei uns
herzlichen dank und ich meine damen und
herren gebe relativ fix rein in den
plenarsaal und zur bundestags
präsidentin bärbel bas
eintritt in die tagesordnung gratuliere
ich nachträglich dem kollegen lars
rohwer und dem kollegen marc bernhard
zum fünfzigsten geburtstag
und der kollegin angelika glöckner zum
sechzigsten geburtstag
im namen des ganzen hauses wünsche ich
ihnen alles gute für das neue lebensjahr
vor eintritt in die tagesordnung haben
wir noch zwei wahlen durchzuführen auf
vorschlag der fraktion die linke soll
die kollegin ina
latendorf als weitere schriftführerin
gewählt werden ich sehe hier keinen
widerspruch dann ist die kollegin
latendorf als schriftführerin gewählt
außerdem sollen auf vorschlag der
fraktionen der spd der kollege martin
dietenhofen sowie auf vorschlag der
fraktion der cdu/csu
der kollege thomas jarzombek als
mitglieder des lenkungskreises des
deutsch-französischen zukunfts werkes
gewählt werden stimmen sie dem zu
das ja wir üben das heute morgen noch
ist noch früh
vielen dank dass sie danach aus das ist
offensichtlich der fall dass sie dem
zustimmen damit sind die kollegen
dietenhofen und jarzombek als mitglieder
des lenkungskreises des
deutsch-französischen zukunfts werkes
gewählt wir kommen zur tagesordnung bei
tagesordnungspunkt 6 soll als weiterer
zusatzpunkt ein antrag der fraktion der
afc auf drucksache 706 aufgerufen werden
ich sehe auch hier keinen widerspruch
dann ist das so beschlossen
ich rufe auf die tagesordnungspunkte 4a
4b sowie 5 bis 5 f
einsetzung des vertrauensgremiums gemäß
§ 10 absatz 2 der bundeshaushaltsordnung
und war seiner mitglieder sowie weitere
wahlen zu gremien
einsetzung des vertrauensgremiums gemäß
§ 10 absatz 2 der bundeshaushaltsordnung
dazu liegt ein gemeinsamer antrag aller
fraktionen auf drucksache
695 vorn wer stimmt für diesen antrag
das sieht danach aus dass das alle
fraktionen des hauses sind wer stimmt
dagegen
niemand enthaltungen sehe ich auch nicht
dann ist der antrag so angenommen damit
ist das vertrauensgremium eingesetzt und
die mitgliederzahl auf 13 festgelegt
wir kommen zu den wahlen mit
stimmzetteln und wahlausweis das ist die
wahl der mitglieder des eben
eingesetzten vertrauensgremiums sowie
die wahl der mitglieder
sowie der stellvertretende mitglieder
des sondergremiums gemäß § 3 absatz 3
des stabilisierungsmechanismus
gesetzes ich bitte schon jetzt die
schriftführerin und schriftführer ihre
plätze an den ausgabe tischen und an den
wahlurnen
einzunehmen den für diese wahlen
erforderlichen orangefarbenen
wahlausweis können sie soweit noch nicht
geschehen den stimmkarten fächern in der
west lobby entnehmen die abgeordneten
auf den tribünen werden ihre
wahlausweise vom planer assistenzdienst
erhalten auf den stimmzetteln sind die
namen der vorgeschlagenen kandidatinnen
und kandidaten auf gefühl geführt
gewählt ist jeweils wer die stimmen der
mehrheit der mitglieder des bundestages
auf sich vereint das heißt wer
mindestens
369 stimmen erhält
zum vertrauensgremium liegen
wahlvorschläge aller fraktionen auf
drucksache 708 vor für die wahl der
mitglieder sowie der stellvertretenden
mitglieder des sondergremiums liegen
wahlvorschläge aller fraktionen auf
drucksache 709 vor die wahlen erfolgen
in der abgeordneten lobby die auf der
tribüne sitzenden kollegen und kollegen
wählen oben auf der tribüne in der
abgeordneten lobby und auf der tribüne
erhalten sie an den ausgabe zwischen
nach vorzeigen ihres wahl ausweises
einen grauen stimmzettel für die wahl
der mitglieder des vertrauensgremiums
einen gelben stimmzettel für die wahl
der mitglieder des sondergremiums
sowie einen grünen stimmzettel für die
wahl der stellvertretenden mitglieder
des sondergremiums
da die wahlen der mitglieder und
stellvertretenden mitglieder des
sondergremiums geheim durchzuführen sind
erhalten sie für diese wahlen zu sie
zusätzlich jeweils einen passenden
wahlumschlag
alle stimmzettel sind in der wahlkabine
anzukreuzen
sie können bei diesen wahlen auf allen
drei stimmzettel neben
jedem kandidatenvorschlag ein kreuz bei
ja nein oder enthaltung machen wenn sie
bei einem nahmen mehr als ein kreuz oder
kein kreuz machen oder anderen namen
oder zusätze eintragen ist diese stimme
ungültig der gelbe stimmzettel ist in
den gelben wahlumschlag der grüne
stimmzettel im grün wahlumschlag zu
legen dies muss in der wahlkabine
erfolgen für den grauen stimmzettel
erhalten sie keinen wahlumschlag da es
sich um eine offene wahl handelt ich
weise noch mal explizit darauf hin dass
das fotografieren oder filmen der
ausgefüllten stimmkarten bei den
geheimen wahlen einen verstoß gegen das
wahlgeheimnis darstellt und die ordnung
und würde des hauses verletzt für den
fall dass sich von solchen verstößen
gegen das wahlgeheimnis in dieser
sitzung oder später kenntnis erlange
behalte ich mir schon jetzt vor
ordnungsmaßnahmen zu ergreifen nach
verlassen der wahlkabine übergeben sie
bitte der schriftführerin oder dem
schriftführer an der wahl ohne ihren
wahlausweis erst danach werfen sie die
beiden wahl umschläge in den griff und
den grauen stimmzettel in die
entsprechend farblich gekennzeichneten
wahl und der nachweis der teilnahme an
der wahl kann nur durch abgabe des
wahlausweise erbracht werden sie haben
zur abgabe ihrer stimmen
90 minuten zeit
haben die schriftführung schriftführer
ihre plätze eingenommen
der daumen ist hoch
dass oben auch das sieht gut aus
dann eröffne ich hiermit die wahl die
schließung der wahlen erfolgt ca 10 uhr
jetzt bitte ich sie noch einen moment im
saal zu bleiben da wir noch fünf walen
mittels handzeichen
durchführen
tagesordnungspunkt 5 wahl der mitglieder
des beirates bei der bundesnetzagentur
für elektrizität gas telekommunikation
post und eisenbahnen
dazu liegen wahlvorschläge aller
fraktionen auf der drucksache 710 vor
wer stimmt für diese wahlvorschläge
wer stimmt dagegen
enthaltungen keinen dann ist das über
alle fraktionen hinweg einstimmig so
angenommen
tagesordnungspunkt 5 c wahl der vom
deutschen bundestag zu benennenden
mitglieder des gemeinsamen
parlamentarischen
kontrollausschusses von europol es lägen
wahlvorschläge der fraktionen der
cdu/csu und spd auf drucksache 711 vor
wer stimmt für diese wahlvorschläge
wer stimmt dagegen
enthaltung keiner dann ist das über alle
fraktionen einstimmig angenommen
tagesordnungspunkt 5 die wahl der
mitglieder des senats des vereins
hermann von helmholtz gemeinschaft
deutscher forschungszentren ev es liegen
wahlvorschläge der fraktionen der spd
und cdu csu fraktion auf drucksache 712
vor wer stimmt für diese wahlvorschläge
wer stimmt dagegen
enthaltungen niemand dann ist das auch
einstimmig über alle fraktionen so
angenommen weil der tagesordnungspunkt 5
wahl der mitglieder des
parlamentarischen beirats der stiftung
für das sorbische volk wir stimmen ab
über die wahlvorschläge der fraktionen
der spd und cdu/csu auf drucksache 713
bestimmt für diese wahlvorschläge
wer stimmt dagegen
enthaltungen
keine dann ist auch das über alle
fraktionen hinweg einstimmig so
angenommen
tagesordnungspunkt 5 wahl der mitglieder
des verwaltungsrates der
filmförderungsanstalt gemäß § 6 des
filmförderungsgesetzes
hierzu liegt ein wahlvorschlag der
fraktion spd cdu/csu und bündnis 90 die
grünen auf drucksache
714 vor bestimmt für diesen
wahlvorschlag
wer stimmt dagegen
enthaltungen
niemand dann ist auch das über alle
fraktionen hinweg einstimmig angenommen
jetzt rufe ich auf die
tagesordnungspunkte 6a und 6b sowie
zusatzpunkt 12 beratung des sechzehnten
entwicklungspolitischen berichts der
bundesregierung sowie beratung der
anträge der fraktion der afg mit den
titeln
strategiewechsel in der
entwicklungspolitik
entwicklungszusammenarbeit im deutschen
interesse und digital politisches
entwicklungsland deutschland fördern
statt block 10 geschäftsmodelle in
afrika für die aussprache ist eine dauer
von
67 minuten beschlossen
ich eröffne die aussprache und das wort
hat die bundesministerin svenja schulze
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren
keines keines der 17 ziele für
nachhaltige entwicklung wird bis 2030
erreicht werden wenn wir in dem
bisherigen tempo weiter machen so steht
es im entwicklungspolitischen bericht
der bundesregierung vom letzten jahr
aber diese regierung hat nicht vor
weiter zu machen wie bisher
ich werde das tempo deutlich erhöhen
und die agenda 20.30 und ihre 17 ziele
sind die richtschnur auch für die
deutsche entwicklungspolitik
ein nachhaltig ganz viel möchte ich hier
heute in dieser debatte ganz besonders
hervorheben und das ist das scp 5 das
sind gleiche rechte und gleiche chancen
für die geschlechter denn das ist ein
wirklich essentielles ziel für eine
starke für eine residente gesellschaft
gleichzeitig ist das scb 5 ein
schlüsselfaktor für die gesamte
nachhaltigkeits eine agenda die
überwindung von armut und hunger können
wir beispielsweise ohne eine echte
gleichstellung nicht erreichen ich werde
deshalb eine feministische
entwicklungspolitik vorantreiben
gemeinsam
was wenn wir gemeinsam tun mit unseren
partnerinnen und partnern in den ländern
des globalen südens aber auch in den
strukturen der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit
geschlechter ungleichheit das sind die
sekte ist das ergebnis diskriminierender
strukturen diskriminierender normen
diskriminierende rollenbilder und ich
bin fest davon überzeugt wer die
menschliche gesellschaft will der muss
die männliche überwinden
minister entwicklungspolitik ist die
gleiche politische wirtschaftliche und
soziale teilhabe aller menschen
unabhängig von ihrem geschlecht von
geschlechtsidentität von sexueller
orientierung und dafür braucht es
gleiche rechte mehr ressourcen und eine
bessere repräsentanz
die voraussetzung für eine echte
gleichstellung sind natürlich gleiche
rechte und ich werde mich dafür
einsetzen dass dem ist diskriminierende
gesetze aufgehoben werden und frauen und
mädchen in allen lebensbereichen
rechtlich gestärkt werden das müssen sie
leider auch aushalten von seiten der afd
ich will den politischen dialog zu
menschenrechtsfragen suchen und
zivilgesellschaftlicher organisationen
in unseren partnerländern fördern
eine feministische entwicklungspolitik
braucht aber auch angemessene ressourcen
sowohl bilateral als auch mutig
multilateral werde ich neue schwerpunkte
setzen und mehr für die gleichstellung
tun und um auch mehr für die
gleichstellung zu erreichen und das
dritte ist die repräsentanz von frauen
auf allen ebenen muss gestärkt werden
wir brauchen frauen am tisch egal ob es
um internationale verhandlungen neue
strategien oder die konzeption eines
neuen vorhabens geht mit mir wird es
keine entscheidung über frauen ohne
frauen gehen
das dass die unsere entwicklungspolitik
ist die gleichstellung nicht nur weil es
gerecht ist sondern auch weil die
ergebnisse dann deutlich besser sind wir
nummer ein beispiel rausnehmen nämlich
die landwirtschaft für einen vielleicht
ein bereich in dem sie das nicht
vermuten aber wenn frauen den gleichen
zugang zu land haben dann erhöht sich
die landwirtschaftliche produktion das
ziel ist natürlich insgesamt die
uneingeschränkte wahrnehmung der
menschenrechte für alle zum beispiel im
bereich der gesundheit das recht auf
gesundheitssicherheit und körperliche
unversehrtheit für frauen vor anderthalb
wochen war der internationale tag gegen
weibliche genitalverstümmelung
durch die korona pandemie sind herbe
rückschläge bei der bekämpfung dieser
schweren form geschlechts basierter
gewalt zu verzeichnen mindestens 200
millionen frauen weltweit müssen mit den
lebenslangen körperlichen und
psychischen folgen leben zwar sind in
zahlreichen ländern diese praktiken
verboten aber es fehlt noch immer an den
nötigen schutz und strafverfolgungs
mechanismen es fehlt an der
unterstützung für die betroffenen
mädchen und frauen das thema weibliche
genitalverstümmlung muss in die
präventionsarbeit gegen geschlechts
basierte gewalt unbedingt einbezogen
werden
also liebe kolleginnen und kollegen es
gibt noch viel zu tun und wie im
koalitionsvertrag vereinbart wird mein
ministerium dafür einen umfassenden
gender aktionsplan unter beteiligung der
zivilgesellschaft
erarbeiten es geht mir nicht um warme
worte sondern um ganz konkret um die
bereitstellung von finanziellen mitteln
in kanada das schon seit vielen jahren
eine feministische außen und
entwicklungspolitik verfolgt fördern 92
prozent der öffentlichen
entwicklungsleistungen auch die
gleichstellung der geschlechter davon
sind wir in deutschland noch weit
entfernt aber ich werde alles dafür tun
um die hebel umzusetzen und dafür setze
ich auch auf ihre unterstützung für
naturschutz die bundesministerin für
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung mit dem
entwicklungspolitischen bericht der
bundesregierung ist es der inzwischen
sechzehnter wir schauen mal kurz in die
lobby in die west lobby des deutschen
bundestages wo es nach wie vor eine sehr
ordentliche schlange gibt mit
abgeordneten die hier abstimmen den
hintergrund laufen ja zwei verfahren mit
wahlen zu
gremienmitgliedern für beispielsweise
das vertrauensgremium dass es vom per
hand abgestimmt werden aber vor allem
auch für das
gremium
für sondergremium sondergremium zum
stabilisierungs mit
mechanismus gesetz ein kompliziertes
wort wir gehen zurück in die debatte in
der jetzt diskutiert wird unter anderem
über das stichwort feministische
entwicklungspolitik der
bundesentwicklungsminister riehen und
georg pieper ist am rednerpult aus der
unionsfraktion
wichtig war der entwicklungspolitik ist
vorherigen kontinuität es macht keinen
sinn wenn innerhalb von einer
legislaturperiode ein themenbereich
herausgegriffen massiv überhöht wird und
alles andere dann was in den vergangenen
jahren an ansätzen geliefert worden ist
nicht weiter verfolgt wird kontinuität
und vor allen dingen strukturiertes
vorgehen auf allen bereichen die die
entwicklungspolitik ausmacht ist das
geheimrezept einer erfolgreichen
verbesserung der lebensverhältnisse für
die menschen rund um den globus und wir
haben auch noch im vergangenen januar
januar 20 21 aus anlass des davoser
wirtschaftsforums ein redebeitrag
unserer ehemaligen bundeskanzlerin
wahrnehmen können der auf seite 2 des
berichts mit einem zitat wiedergegeben
worden ist und gerade in den kritischen
phasen von pandemien und krisen ist es
nicht angezeigt die tätigkeit zu
reduzieren oder auszusetzen sondern ganz
im gegenteil es muss wie es da so schön
steht zitat eine schippe draufgelegt
werden und das werden wir in zukunft tun
müssen aber verehrte frau ministerin wir
werden natürlich mal schauen ob es ihnen
denn gelingt diesen furiosen aufwuchs
der letzten acht jahre von
6,3 millionen euro haushaltsvolumen auf
13,4 millionen euro einer fast
verdoppeln
umzusetzen oder fortzusetzen ich wünsche
ihnen viel erfolg in den
haushaltsberatungen mit ihrem
finanzminister christian lindner der
immerhin einer partei angehört die in
der legislaturperiode 9 bis 13
eigentlich alles daran gesetzt hat um
das bnz abzuschaffen viel erfolg und
viel vergnügen bei diesem unterfangen
wir werden sie an diesen leistungen
messen
[Applaus]
ich will aber kurz referieren was in
diesem bericht zu recht ausgeführt
worden ist und wo die wesentlichen
punkte einer erfolgreichen
entwicklungspolitik liegen man hat sich
dem hunger dem dem ausbau der bildung
der bekämpfung der armut der ausrottung
der krankheiten der reduzierung der
müttersterblichkeit und natürlich auch
werden zurückdrängen der uns immer noch
belastenden krankheit hiv/aids gewidmet
ja richtig der erfolg ist noch nicht
vollendet das ist allerdings bei dieser
enormen herausforderung auch mehr als
nachvollziehbar und es gibt leider immer
wieder rückschläge die 2014 etwa die
ebola
krise und auch jetzt die korona pandemie
aber es muss fortgesetzt werden und da
sind aus meiner sicht in den vergangenen
jahren vollkommen zu recht die richtigen
vier säulen aufgebaut worden um das dach
der entwicklungspolitik stützen zu
stützen stärken der eigenen initiativen
und bildung gleichberechtigung und
armutsbekämpfung
stärkung auch privater investitionen
denn unter die privatwirtschaft lässt
sich eine nachhaltige
wirtschaftsbelebung in
entwicklungsländern nicht realisieren
innovations- und technologietransfer
moderne möglichkeiten wie die
digitalisierung sind unverzichtbarer
bestandteil in der entwicklungspolitik
und natürlich und nicht zuletzt den
aufbau von fairen handel denn
wirtschaftliche tätigkeit besteht
natürlich auch im austausch von
leistungen und dazu haben in der letzten
legislaturperiode das lieferketten
gesetz auf den weg gebracht mein kollege
wird dazu noch weiteres ausführen und
ein
grundlegende erfolg der soll nicht
unerwähnt bleiben an dieser stelle es
ist das 0,7 prozent ziel erreicht worden
lange jahre haben wir darauf
hingearbeitet in der letzten
legislaturperiode ist es gelungen also
versprochen und gehalten
die cdu hat verlässliche entwicklungs
politik gemacht man
kann nicht in der verbleibenden redezeit
sicherlich nicht die gesamten 388 seiten
referieren und vorstellen deshalb will
ich aufgrund meiner persönlichen
tätigkeit im rahmen der globalen
gesundheit gerne die aktuell aktualität
der entwicklungspolitik im rahmen der
kapo oder pandemie bekämpfung kurze
skizzieren das ist keine aufgabe die wir
in deutschland alleine leisten können
wir brauchen verlässliche und vor allen
dingen vernetzten partner und da haben
wir seit jahren auf die zusammenarbeit
und die unterstützung von javi der
internationalen allianz den gf atm aber
vor allen dingen auch der wehr gesetzt
die koordinierend weltweit die pandemie
bekämpfung vorantreiben muss waits oder
johann fbi waren partner die von der
bundesrepublik mit signifikanten mitteln
gestützt wurden und die auf diese art
und weise
zuverlässig weltweit und für alle
menschen auf diesem planeten leistungen
erbringen können und wir waren auch in
der lage
akute
ereignisse zu erwidern im
juni 2020 ist mit entdecken
beziehungsweise dem fortschreiten der
korona pandemie sofort ein weltweites
kroner sofort programm mit einem volumen
von 4,7 milliarden euro um gesteuert
worden um dann die zur verfügung
stehenden mittel zielgenau einzusetzen
alleine
schaffen wir die aufgaben die es
weltweit gibt sicherlich nicht wir
brauchen partner wir brauchen
zusammenarbeit wir brauchen vernetzung
aber eins ist auf jeden fall klar und
das ist vielleicht den einzigen satz den
ich auf den antrag der alv sie
verschwenden will
entwicklungspolitik ist zukunftspolitik
und entwicklungspolitik ist frieden und
sicherheitspolitik und es ist unter
keinen umständen vertretbar da in
irgendeiner form einen strategiewechsel
eintreten zu lassen denn damit werden
die erfolge die ihnen den vergangenen
acht jahren unter gerd müller und angela
merkel erzielt worden sind zunichte
gemacht dann nützt es auch nichts einen
aktuellen titel der feministischen
entwicklungspolitik zu sehen sie
brauchen strukturierte politik bei der
alle menschen alle gruppen alle
kontinente gleichermaßen
berücksichtigung finden und nur so wird
es gelingen ein nächstes kapitel in
diesem erfolgs in dieser
erfolgsgeschichte zu schreiben
wir werden sie an den aussagen und an
den ankündigungen und messen aber wir
sind durchaus schon skeptisch ob das
nach diesen ersten ansätzen überhaupt
gelingen wird herzlichen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
georg kippels war das aus der
unionsfraktion und ich bitte um
entschuldigung für den versprecher bei
seinem namen hat sich hin wohin
angekündigt habe an der stadt broker
wird die nächste rednerin sein
stellvertretende vorsitzende der
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen während
in der west lb weiterhin fröhlich
abgestimmt wird wie sie jetzt gleich
wieder sehen bei uns das wird auch noch
eine weile so dauer andauern das geht
wie gesagt um das sondergremium zum
stabilisierungsmechanismusgesetz tanja
brugger
aber in der tat herr kollege kipp ist es
gibt auch durchaus ein gericht ein haben
sie erwähnt dass lieferketten gesetzt
aber wenn ich mich recht entsinne ist es
über jahre hinweg ja gerade aus dem
kanzleramt aus dem
wirtschaftsministerium blockiert worden
weil es nicht unbedingt das
herzensprojekt der cdu und hier haben
viele in diesem haus große widerstände
auch mit der zivilgesellschaft mit den
kirchen und im unternehmen überwunden
das ist endlich kommt und der nächste
wichtige schritt ist dieses lieferketten
gesetz nun zu europäisieren ihm dadurch
mehr werk kraft zu verleihen und dafür
zu sorgen dass umweltzerstörung und
menschenrechtsverletzung hat kein
geschäftsmodell der zukunft mehr sein
und herr kollege kippels sie haben ja
auch recht ist es auch sicherlich ein
lichtblick dass die 0,7 prozent für
entwicklung am bruttonationaleinkommen
endlich erreicht worden sind nach 50
jahren aber auch hier sozusagen lohnt es
sich einmal genauer hinzuschauen denn
wenn wir uns anschauen was die alte
bundesregierung mit ihrer
mittelfristigen finanzplanung vorgelegt
hat dann ist das eine fallende linie und
es geht nicht darum die 0,7 prozent zu
sichern solange herr müller im amt ist
sondern in einer welt in der die krisen
zunehmend dass eine pandemie gibt die
klimakrise armut hunger und krieg wieder
zunehmen da braucht es ein mehr an
internationaler gerechtigkeit ein mehr
an solidarität und deshalb haben wir im
koalitionsvertrag
verankert dass wir mindestens diese 0,7
prozent in zukunft garantieren wollen
und dass wir auch bei der
klimafinanzierung brauchen
und liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wenn
man diesen mehrere hundert seiten langen
bericht durchliest dann gewinnt man so
einen eindruck und den hatte ich in den
vergangenen jahren auch hier in unseren
debatten da war immer ein minister der
schöne bücher geschrieben hat tolle
termine in anderen ländern in den
wahlkreisen gemacht hat flammende
appelle hier gehalten hat und eine
bundesregierung mit sehr vielen ressorts
die sich nicht so sehr um die fragen von
globaler gerechtigkeit und
internationaler solidarität gekümmert
haben der nächste bericht dieser neuen
bundesregierung muss einen bericht der
gesamten bundesregierung werden denn in
einer hoch vernetzten welt hat alles was
wir tun oder und auch alles was wir
nicht tun immer wieder auch auswirkungen
in anderen kontinenten der welt und
deshalb ist globale gerechtigkeit sind
die nachhaltigkeitsziele der agenda
20.30 nicht die aufgabe eines ressorts
sondern natürlich für die ganze
bundesregierung
und da bin ich bei dem was sich auch
ändern muss wir müssen mehr tun für
klimaschutz und klimagerechtigkeit
wir sehen doch das ist die
industriestaaten sind die den großteil
der emissionen verursachen und das ist
die menschen im globalen süden sind die
am meisten unter den klimaschäden leiden
und wir müssen mehr tun indem wir bei
uns unsere emissionen reduzieren und
daran arbeiten in dieser bundesregierung
viele häuser gemeinsam zusammen und
nicht mehr gegeneinander
wir müssen aber auch mit entwicklungs
und klima partnerschaften gemeinsamen
gewinn für alle generieren und natürlich
auch mehr im bereich laws and damaged
frau bürger gestalten sie eine
zwischenfrage aus der fw fraktion
aber auch globale gesundheit müssen wir
stärken und da denke ich auch wirklich
der zivilgesellschaft die einerseits
natürlich immer wieder anerkennt dass
deutschland hier schon viel tut aber
andererseits auch sehr deutlich macht
dass wir mehr tun müssen für die globale
gerechtigkeit
und frau ministerin wir freuen uns
natürlich sehr dass sie hier so
prominent eines unserer herzensanliegen
dass sich ja auch sehr prominent im
koalitionsvertrag wieder findet
angesprochen haben eine feministische
perspektiven in der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit und das ist
ja genau der gedanke der dahinter steht
eine politik für entwicklung für
nachhaltigkeit von der am ende alle
profitieren die gesamte gesellschaft wo
wir aber auch ein blick darauf haben das
ist gerade frauen mädchen
marginalisierte gruppen sind für die von
den krisen anders oft auch stärker
betroffen werden das sehen wir auch in
der pandemie sind frauen und die sehr
stark im gesundheitssektor arbeiten es
sind die mädchen die vielleicht nicht
wieder zur schule gehen können oder
schulbetrieb ausgesetzt worden sind und
deshalb freuen wir uns auf das kapitel
zur feministischen entwicklungspolitik
im neuen bericht der bundesregierung
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich
wünsche mir aber auch für diesen neuen
bericht eines dass er nicht ein bericht
wird wo sich eine bundesregierung selber
auf die schulter klopft sondern dass es
ein bericht wird denn der klare analyse
hat da auch eine ehrliche evaluation
freundin dessen was wir vielleicht nicht
erreicht haben und warum wir das nicht
getan haben und dessen was besser werden
muss eine strategie für die zukunft fest
schreibt ein bericht der klar macht das
handeln der ganzen bundesregierung fühlt
sich verpflichtet der globalen
gerechtigkeit den nachhaltigkeitszielen
der vereinten nationen und der
internationalen solidarität vielen dank
dann herrscht darüber war dass
stellvertretende vorsitzende der
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen in der
aussprache zum entwicklungspolitischen
bericht der bundesregierung und der
höheren jetzt dieter friedhof aus der
fdp-fraktion die afg hat zwei anträge
vorgelegt deren titel ich jeden
wenigstens vorlesen will
strategiewechsel in der
entwicklungspolitik
entwicklungszusammenarbeit im deutschen
interesse ist der eine überschrieben und
der andere heißt digital politisches
entwicklungsland deutschland fördern
statt im block chain geschäftsmodelle in
afrika aber jetzt die immer friedhof in
amerika und afrika schaut auf unser land
das ohne not gefahren wird vor die wand
wer vor wer fährt des vor die wand und
macht es krank er ist die alte nun auch
die neue regierungsbank mit deutschland
klappt es nicht so richtig deswegen
rettet auch die neue ministerin gleich
die ganze menschheit wichtig wagen wir
nach neun jahren minister müller
einblick in das illusionstheater der
gedruckten
entwicklungspolitischen erfolglos
geschichten und vorhang auf für die welt
der realität afrika ist fragiler und
zerrissener denn je krieger ausbeutung
hunger und armut wie nie das reichste
afrikanische land nigeria mit 200
millionen einwohnern hat eine geringere
wirtschaftsleistung als berlin und das
obwohl nigeria zu den rohstoffreichsten
ländern afrikas gehört die gesamte
wirtschaftsleistung afrikas ist die
geringer als die noch
wirtschaftsleistung deutschland afrika
benötigt die unterstützung zur
gestaltung eines geschlossenen
binnenmarktes aufbau von
wertschöpfungsketten im bereich der
rohstoff veredelung und für die
umsetzung der agenda 20 63 die
afrikanischen union für deutschland will
europa nicht zwischen den machtblöcken
der usa und china zerrieben werden
bietet sich der afrikanische kontinent
verein gemeinsam
partnerschaftliche wirtschaftsaufschwung
dazu an und jagt der kontinent bietet
nicht nur chancen er hat von dem viele
herausforderungen dabei müssen wir
endlich aufhören den kontinent zu
bevormunden der echte teilhabe will muss
mit dem eurozentristisch 'nen klima
feministischen quer geänderten
links-grün kultur kolonialismus endlich
auf erleben
60 jahre entwicklungspolitik und kein
bisschen weise könnte man da ein wenig
mit
südafrikas eben auch durch eine falsch
verstandene hilfs politik korrupter denn
je der politische islam mit seinen
kampftruppen ist wieder erstarkt und die
bevölkerungsexplosion das größte problem
der entwicklungsländer
er zieht jedem gedachten erfolg gleich
wieder den boden so auch im bereich herr
doktor hofft man im bereich der
weltwirtschaft solange die bäume afrikas
nicht nur in china sondern eben auch in
einem ungeheuren tempo unter den
kochtöpfen afrikas damit wir in der
realität bleiben bis zum jahr 2050
steigt die bevölkerungszahl den
afrikanern 1,2 milliarden menschen sie
steigt an um 1,2 milliarden menschen
dass sie mehr menschen als in den
nordamerikanischen staaten in europa und
russland zusammen leben sie kommen
einfach dazu ich glaube wer das nicht
bedenkt hat wirklich realität verlust
aber wir haben einen echten vorteil mit
der neuen bundesregierung die 70 oder 17
nachhaltigkeitsziele wollen ja dass die
lebensrealitäten der menschen sich
anpassen wo liebes schwellenländer wenn
ihr noch etwas wartet kann ich euch
versprechen wir sind bald bei euch
angekommen
deutschland ist im bereich der
digitalität absolutes entwicklungsland
welt weit abgeschlagen und die neue
entwicklungsministerin sie gerade in
unserer digital kompetenz ungeheure
möglichkeiten und das ist kein scherz
die fähigkeiten unseres staates auf
katastrophen zu reagieren ist eine
absolute katastrophe
das aatal beweist einmal mehr
deutschland kann es sieht vielen
bereichen nicht mehr das sehen wir uns
auch im bereich der deutschen
infrastruktur der energieversorgung der
bildung und gerade auch in unserem
veränderten demokratieverständnis
deutschland wird entwicklungsland gesamt
entwicklungspolitische und afghanistan
mali äthiopien und burkina faso mahnung
warnung und gerade auch anstoß zum
umdenken sagt für eine rasante
entwicklung werte vor ministerin stoppen
sie endlich das entwicklungs lusi owns
theater und bmw den linken ideologie
betrieb und starten sie endlich den
humanen wirtschaftsteil habe vernunft
betrieb zum wohle der menschen symbole
der welt und vor allem eins zum wohle
deutschlands
der bundestag diskutiert über den
entwicklungspolitischen bericht der
bundesregierung und dazu passt eine
meldung die gerade als eilmeldung über
die agenturen gegangen ist denn europa
und kanada beenden den
anti-terror-einsatz in mali heißester
bei der deutschen presse-agentur
frankreich seine europäischen partner
und kanada beenden den militärischen
anti-terror-einsatz im westafrikanischen
mali man wolle in der sahelzone aber
weiterhin aktiv bleiben hintergrund ist
unter anderem dass die malische
regierung
militärregierung nicht richtig richtig
kooperieren möchte mit den kräften die
eigentlich den terror in mali beenden
sollten wir gehen wieder
ins plenum und zu knut kircher aus der
fdp-fraktion der hier gerade seine erste
rede hält
ist bunt bebildert und grafisch
ansprechend die äußere hülle ist dabei
aber dass eine der inhalt das andere der
bericht benennt viele erfolge aber er
zeigt auch schwachstellen auf wir freien
demokraten haben klare vorstellungen
über die schwerpunkte der entwicklung
des politischen zusammenarbeit in dieser
legislaturperiode vier aspekte möchte
ich da stellen die mir besonders wichtig
sind doch vorher möchte ich einen
grundsatz vorausschicken den ich durch
meine erfahrung in der
entwicklungspolitik gelernt habe wenn
man menschen die chance gut ihr leben
und ihr umfeld selbst in die hand zu
nehmen so ist das besser als jede
staatliche hilfe mit der gießkanne
multilateralismus eine internationale
zusammenarbeit ist nötiger denn je die
ersten ansätze zeigt der bericht auf in
manchen ländern setzt deutschland nicht
mehr
auf bilaterale kooperation sondern
beteiligt sich an multinationalen
strategien wir setzen auf starke
allianzen um entwicklungspolitik
effizienter zu machen erfolge lassen
sich so auch besser bewerten
klimapolitik für das klima gilt wie
retten es weltweit oder gar nicht dazu
müssen wir alles dransetzen um die
nutzung erneuerbarer energien in afrika
und lateinamerika
voranzubringen wir fordern aber auch
eine bessere globale verknüpfung der
vorschriften zum zertifikate handel mit
emissionen um die interessen der
entwicklungsländer
einzubringen gerade im klimabereich
sehe ich auch eine große chance für eine
beteiligung der privatwirtschaft diese
besitzt die mittel und das know how um
eine energiewende wende zu unterstützen
frauen und mädchen
das ist ein punkt den wir mehr in den
fokus rücken wollen die stärkung der
rechte von frauen und mädchen dies hat
nichts mit sendern zeitgeist zu tun
sondern mit einem plan blick auf die
fakten fehlendes wissen um
familienplanung mangelhafte
gesundheitsvorsorge
eine noch nach wie vor hohe
müttersterblichkeit das sind die fakten
und wir werden die produktive und
sexuelle rechte von frauen fördern durch
informations offensive
durch dienste zur familienplanung durch
kontrazeptiva auch dazu ist ein
international abgestimmtes vorgehen
nötig dabei dürfen übrigens eins nicht
vergessen die männer mit auf diesem weg
mitzunehmen
beteiligung der privatwirtschaft es gilt
den teil wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit
in der bezeichnung des ministeriums
klarer herauszustellen erste ansätze wie
der compact for africa haben bislang
noch nicht die geplante resonanz gehabt
es bestehen immer noch viele sorgen und
vorteile wenn es um investitionen in
afrika geht sagen wir aber ehrlich meine
damen und herren alle mittel der
entwicklungspolitik ob aus deutschland
ob aus europa oder global können den
wirtschaftlichen fortschritt in
entwicklungsländern und schwellenländer
nicht allein voran bringen wir brauchen
dazu auch privatwirtschaftliches
engagement
sehr geehrte damen und herren ein
gedanke solche immer dabei sein und
damit komme ich auch zum schluss
entwicklungspolitik soll unterstützen
soll helfen aber entwicklungspolitik
darf nicht auf dauer abhängig machen
manche länder und organisationen
gewöhnen sich sehr schnell an
regelmäßige zahlungen wir wollen eine
entwicklungspolitik bei der die länder
immer eigenverantwortliche und
selbstbewusster die zukunft ihrer länder
in die hand nehmen vielen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
im zentrum wird weiter über den
entwicklungspolitischen bericht der
bundesregierung diskutiert hin der
westlotto stehen die abgeordneten nach
wie vor schlange für abstimmungen die
dann in der abgeordneten lobby
stattfinden wo es um das sondergremium
zum
stabilisierungsmechanismus gesetz geht
und wir blicken 6 zurück ins plenum da
ist nämlich schon am pult cornelia
möhring aus der linksfraktion sprecherin
für entwicklungspolitik die
kolleginnen und kollegen frau minister
und schulze auch die linke will deutlich
mehr tempo und eine feministische
entwicklungszusammenarbeit aber gerade
deshalb würden wir sie anders ausrichten
die interessen und bedürfnisse der
menschen innen unterstützen ländern in
den mittelpunkt orientiert an den
gedanken vor gerecht von gerechtigkeit
solidarität und nachhaltigkeit und stadt
in erster linie den
wirtschaftsinteressen der geberländer
und den konzern vorrang einzuräumen
würden wir eine globale umverteilung
einleiten um soziale ungleichheit zu
bekämpfen sie machen das leider nicht so
oder nicht konsequent ein dramatisches
beispiel dafür ist afghanistan und die
zur verantwortung für die
zurückgelassenen arbeitskräfte liegen
auch bei ihrem ministerium die lage der
zivilbevölkerung wird immer
katastrophaler die wirtschaft des landes
ist weitgehend zusammengebrochen viele
haben ihren job verloren die meisten
menschen haben kaum noch geld und leiden
unter extremen hunger die übergriffe
gerade gegenüber frauen aktivisten sind
auf der tagesordnung und mittendrin im
elend und der zunehmenden gefahr
tausende zurückgelassene ehemalige
ortskräfte und ihre familien die nun um
ihr leben bangen und was noch das bmz
das bmz lind ausreiseanträge ab weil die
betroffenen nur einen honorarvertrag
hatten das ist unverantwortlich die
taliban bekannt
telefon schutz vor ort arbeitsvertrag
oder honorar tätigkeit und da sie ja
vorhin frau kollegin broker hat erwähnt
die ganze bundesregierung sich zuständig
fühlt es braucht jetzt wiesen nach
ankunft und eine doppelte luftbrücke
hilfsgüter hin bedrohte zurück
verhandeln sie die aufnahme der
direktflüge und sorgen sie dafür dass
humanitäre hilfe schnell bei den
betroffenen ankommt ist schon sehr
enttäuschend wie behäbig die von spd und
grünen geführten ministerien hier
agieren das gilt auch für das thema im
gerechtigkeit während hier gepostet wird
was ihr gut ist waren im januar 22 05
prozent der menschen in ärmeren ländern
vollständig geimpft nur fünf prozent
hatten die erste impfung in einer
solchen situation wird der
bundeswirtschaftsminister robert habeck
zum umfaller des monats und ändert nach
einem gespräch mit der pharmaindustrie
seiner haltung zur patent aussetzung ich
finde das unglaublich
der schnelle ausbau von
produktionskapazitäten ist wichtig um
die verfügbarkeit zu erhöhen und zwar
nachhaltig auch um schnell auf
notwendige anpassungen an neue varianten
reagieren zu können in kapstadt gibt es
jetzt zwar fortschritte bei der
entwicklung eines eigenen impfstoffes
mit patent freigabe wäre das aber
deutlich schneller möglich gewesen und
ohne wird weiterhin wertvolle zeit
verloren nach presseberichten hat björn
czech sogar versucht die erforschung
eines afrikanischen impfstoffs zu
verhindern angesichts des profits von
1000 dollar pro sekunde kein wunder ein
unternehmen bleibt eben ein unternehmen
und diese zeiten lieber konkurrenz aus
als sie neben sich zu dulden
aber genau das liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen zeigt warum wir forschungen
pharmazie gesundheit nicht dem markt
überlassen dürfen darüber kann im
übrigen auch das gestrige werbe event in
marburg nicht hinwegtäuschen dass sich
ja so abfeiern unter dem deckmantel des
technologietransfers wird mit fabrik
containern die eigene produktion
ausgebaut das ganze dauert zudem viel zu
lange sollen nämlich mindestens zwei
jahre da die pandemie liegt aber keine
pause ein anders als sie behaupten gibt
es mindestens 120 pharmafirmen globalen
süden die in deutlich kürzerer zeit die
produktion aufnehmen könnten wenn es
denn den technologietransfer gebe für
die logik des marktes gilt profite vor
gesundheit und deshalb muss die
gesundheit dem markt entzogen werden
geben sie endlich die patente frau
fordert cornelia möhring die sprecherin
für entwicklungspolitik in der fraktion
die linke im deutschen bundestag der
weiterhin über den
entwicklungspolitischen bericht der
bundesregierung im diskutiert und da
kommt jetzt rebecca scheinbar ans pult
aus der spd-fraktion auch sie wird jetzt
gleich ihre erste rede halten und
kollegen in diesem jahr werden
274 millionen menschen auf humanitäre
hilfe angewiesen sein
vergangenes jahr waren 84 millionen
menschen auf der flucht
45 millionen menschen droht eine
hungersnot
die lage ist dramatisch
wir dürfen uns an diesen zustand nicht
gewöhnen nicht abstumpfen sondern wir
müssen immer wieder genau hinsehen denn
über viele krisen wird kaum mehr
berichtet sie werden schlicht vergessen
was also tun angesichts dieses globalen
ausnahmezustands der sechzehnte
entwicklungspolitische bericht der
bundesregierung stellt richtigerweise
fest
entwicklungspolitik ist zukunfts und
friedenspolitik damit frieden aber
nachhaltig bestand hat braucht es in
zukunft eine bessere ressort
übergreifende zusammenarbeit und einen
systematischen ansatz der
krisenprävention
konfliktbewältigung und
friedensförderung
wir werden uns jetzt gemeinsam mit
unseren koalitionspartnerinnen und
partnern genau auf diesen weg begeben
mehr noch es wird einen grundlegenden
wandel in der entwicklungspolitik geben
im stil und in der sache wir werden
schluss machen mit ressort spezifischen
eitelkeiten da möchte ich mich an dieser
stelle bei den drei ministerinnen svenja
schulze annalena baerbock und christine
lambrecht bedanken die bereits sehr
deutlich gemacht haben dass
entwicklungs- außen und
verteidigungsministerium künftig mit
gemeinsamer stimme sprechen werden uns
geht es um kohärentes internationales
handeln und darum deutschlands rolle bei
der entschärfung internationaler krisen
weiter auszubauen
die leitlinien krisenprävention sind
hierfür eine hervorragende grundlage
wir werden den vernetzten ansatz weiter
stärken und mit leben füllen und die
ministerin hat es gesagt unsere
entwicklungspolitik wird für minister
sein mir ist bewusst dass sich der ein
oder andere hier im raum noch mit diesem
begriff anfreunden muss ich will ihnen
aber gerne erläutern warum eine
feministische entwicklungspolitik genau
der richtige schritt ist um auf frieden
zu fördern die zahlen sind eindeutig
wenn frauen an friedensverhandlungen und
zwar von beginn an beteiligt sind steigt
die chance dass es erstens überhaupt zu
einem friedensvertrag kommt und zweitens
dass der frieden länger hält im sommer
deutlich zu machen handeln frauen
friedensabkommen mit aus steigt die
chance dass der frieden länger als zwei
jahre hält um 20 prozent
mit der resolution 13 25 aus dem jahre
2000 wurde das auch von den vereinten
nationen anerkannt zu dieser resolution
dieser resolution ist es dass frauen an
friedensverhandlungen beteiligt sind und
so geschlechterspezifische perspektiven
einbezogen werden über 20 jahre später
müssen wir feststellen dass
friedensverhandlungen immer noch
überwiegend von männern geführt werden
leider hat auch deutschland in der
vergangenheit nicht viel daran
mitgewirkt dass sich dieser zustand
ändert und genau deshalb braucht es
jetzt eine feministische
entwicklungspolitik weil es schlicht und
ergreifend sinn macht
es neu gewählte abgeordnete freue ich
mich daher dass wir sie im
koalitionsvertrag vereinbart haben und
besonders freut mich dass dieser wandel
auch auf der regierungsbank sichtbar ist
entwicklungs außen und
verteidigungsministerium in der hand von
drei kompetenten frauen
es geht aber nicht nur um mehr frauen in
verantwortung sondern darum das thema
gleichstellung stellung ins zentrum zu
stellen ungleiche machtstrukturen in den
blick zu nehmen und gemeinsam mit
unseren partnerinnen und partnern zu
verändern meine damen und herren die
globalen herausforderungen vor denen wir
stehen sind immens die zahlen sind
schlicht nicht hinnehmbar
ich bin aber der festen überzeugung dass
wir einen entscheidenden beitrag dazu
leisten können ja sogar leisten müssen
diesen weltweiten krisen zu begegnen
jetzt ist die zeit für gemeinsames
handeln hier in deutschland in europa
aber vor allem auf augenhöhe mit unseren
partnerinnen und partnern im globalen
süden jetzt die zeit für eine
entwicklungszusammenarbeit die sich eben
nicht als karitative zu versteht sondern
tatsächliche transformation also einen
grundlegenden wandel im sinne der un
nachhaltigkeitsziele anstrebt herzlichen
dank
und das war die erste redet und rebecca
scheinbar im deutschen bundestag ließ
mitglied der spd fraktion und hat noch
einmal betont warum feministische
entwicklungs und auch friedenspolitik
wichtig ist sind aus ihrer sicht
die den wahlgang von heute morgen auf
circa 11 uhr auf wunsch verschiedener
fraktionen so dass sie das in ihren
fraktionen noch einmal ihren kolleginnen
und kollegen mitteilen können um 11 uhr
schließen wir dann den wahlgang für die
geheimen wahlen jetzt hat das wort für
die cdu csu fraktion dr wolfgang steffel
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin werte
kolleginnen und kollegen ich darf
beginnen und auch meiner freude
dahingehend ausdruck verleihen dass wir
zu so prominenter zeit dieses wichtige
thema der wirtschaftlichen
zusammenarbeit und entwicklung
diskutierenden internationale
zusammenarbeit und wirtschaftliche
kooperation mit entwicklungs und
schwellenländern hat nämlich sehr viel
mit respekt und partnerschaftlichem
handel mit fragen der menschenwürde mit
fragen zum schutz des planeten und auch
mit friedenssicherung zu tun themen
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren
die uns als union wichtig sind themen
die auch minister müller und die
unionsgeführte bundesregierung in den
letzten jahren massiv voran gebracht
haben leider muss ich allerdings
feststellen dass wir hier jetzt von
kohärenten handeln und von der
wichtigkeit kollegen von den grünen von
der spd angesprochen wie wichtig die
zusammenarbeit zwischen den ministerien
hier sei dann frage ich mich schon wo
ist die verteidigungsministerien wo ist
die aussenministerin die regierungsbank
ist hier nicht besetzt bzw nur mit
staatssekretären
anders meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren kann ich mir auch nicht erklären
und deswegen frage ich mich schon welche
wichtigkeit diese themen in dieser ampel
regierung spielen die gestrige
abstimmung im ausschuss für
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung dass dieser ausschuss ab
sofort auf den nachmittag verlegt wird
ein rumpf ausschuss wird was die
zeitliche behandlung von themen betrifft
denn für alle die die geschäftsordnung
nicht wissen nicht kennen wir können nur
noch themen behandelt wenn nichts
wichtigeres im plenum behandelt wird und
es wird dieser verantwortung nicht
gerecht meine sehr geehrten damen und
herren das heißt nämlich
es heißt nämlich dass die themen
menschenwürde respekt schutz des
planeten nur noch dann auf die
tagesordnung kommen wenn halt im plenum
nichts wichtigeres ist und dass meine
sehr geehrten damen und herren wird vor
allem auch im moralischen ansprüchen die
er insbesondere auch die fraktion der
grünen immer so gerne vor sich her
tragen nicht gerecht anders kann ich mir
das nämlich nicht erklären ich darf auch
nur erinnern an die debatten die wir in
der letzten periode hier geführt haben
zum thema transparenz und lobbyismus
aber jetzt hat ziehen ja neuerdings die
aktivisten auch ins haus ein offenbar
ist der neue leitsatz der grünen wir
reden nicht mit lobbyisten der beamten
sie in unseren häusern
meine
sehr geehrten damen und herren
die hat müller hat das thema der
wirtschaftlichen zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung wie kein minister vor ihm in
die öffentlichkeit getragen und auch
hier ins parlament wir haben den
haushalt massiv erhöht unter der
regierungszeit von bundeskanzlerin
angela merkel verdreifacht und in den
acht jahren von gerd müller verdoppelt
frau ministerin ich bin gespannt ob ihre
regierung ähnliches hinbekommt sollten
sie das schaffen haben sie meinen
respekt verdient ich bin gespannt die
haushaltswoche im märz wird wird es
zeigen
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren der
bericht der bundesregierung macht eines
ganz klar wir als union sind unserer
verantwortung gerecht geworden in den
vergangenen jahren die zahl der
hungernden hatte sich bis zum einsetzen
der korona pandemie massivst reduziert
die gesundheitsversorgung wurde
ausgebaut die bildungsangebote wurden
gestärkt klima und umweltschutz ist
gestärkt worden übrigens von 2 auf mehr
als fünf milliarden euro und hier wird
es auch spannend sein frau ministerin
sie sich mit ihren beiden kollegen von
den grünen hier nicht gegenseitig auf
den füßen stehen werden der größere
klimaschützer ist besonders spannend ist
ja aktuell auch die schlagzeile berg
fliegt linie ich kann nur eine sage ich
entspannen dass man darauf hinweisen
muss dass eine grüne ministerin linie
fliegt gerd müller ist meistens münchen
geflogen übrigens in der vergangenheit
das war selten eine schlagzeile aber
offenbar wird es dem wähler klientel und
insbesondere dem grünen klientel gerecht
weil das wohl dort eher unüblich ist
linie zu fliegen sondern vielleicht eher
der privatjet genommen wird
meine
sehr geehrte
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren wir
sind uns im ziel einig dass wir die
entwicklungsländer unterstützen müssen
dass wir diese stärken müssen dass wir
auch win win situationen haben und hier
gemeinsam profitieren können ich kann
ihnen nur sagen es wird mit staatlicher
unterstützung alleine nicht gehen und
frau ministerin sie
finden einen marshallplan in afrika vor
sie finden den wirtschafts investitions
vor vor vor hier sind große leitplanken
gesetzt worden der reformprozess bmz
2030 ist eingesetzt also ich kann sie
nur drauf nur auffordern bauen sie auch
diesem starken fundament von gerd müller
auf das haus ist gut bestellt es liegt
an ihnen etwas daraus zu machen vielen
dank
rolf klein steht finger war das aus der
csu landesgruppe also aus der
unionsfraktion und weil er sich gefragt
hat wo die außenministerin und die
verteidigungsministerin den sei da
können wir zumindest einem fall aus
helfen nämlich in der frage zur
bundesverteidigungsministerium die ist
beim nato verteidigungsminister treffen
in brüssel da wurden die beratungen
heute morgen um 9 uhr fortgesetzt und
die bekannten themen sind ja immer noch
dieselben jannik klaus giesen hohes ist
am pult für die fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen gute entwicklungszusammenarbeit
zeichnet sich vor allem dadurch aus dass
sie sich konsequent an den echten bedarf
der partnerländer ausrichtet das problem
ist in den vergangenen jahren ist ein
ganz ganz vielen stellen an den echten
bedarf der partnerländer vorbei
gearbeitet worden und ihr bericht zeigt
übrigens auch der bericht der
vorgängerregierung die gründe dafür
punkt eins an ganz vielen stellen ist
die entwicklungszusammenarbeit für
nationale interessen instrumentalisiert
worden und punkt zwei da wo gute ansätze
da waren da sind sie ganz oft durch
wirtschaftliche lobbyinteressen
verbessert worden daran hatte die union
einen großen anteil das ist keine global
gerechte politik das ist unglaubwürdig
und das werden wir beenden meine damen
und herren ich
würde ihnen ich will ihnen ein paar
beispiele geben was wir dringend ändern
müssen und um an erster stelle direkt
mal mit einem mythos aufzuräumen es ist
eben nicht genug getan worden für
klimaschutz für biodiversitätsschutz die
bedarf es sind hier viel viel größer und
wir müssen hier mehr tun
anderes thema das hier auch sehr
ausgestellt haben die zusammenarbeit mit
der privatwirtschaft in der
entwicklungspolitik ich meine ich habe
da selber gearbeitet und ich kann sagen
da gibt es auch gute einzelprojekte das
problem ist aber dass ein ganz ganz
vielen stellen viel zu sehr auf masse
und nicht auf qualität gesetzt worden
ist und so geht's nicht weiter
passend dazu auch das thema lieferketten
gesetz ist ja hier vorher auch schon mal
so ein bisschen ab gefeiert worden die
wahrheit ist doch dass am ende zu wenig
erreicht worden ist für umwelt und
menschenrechte übrigens auch weil
wirtschaftliche lobbyinteressen unter
anderem auch vorgetragen durch die union
dazu geführt haben dass dieses gesetz
verbessert worden ist was wir jetzt
brauchen weil das hier auf europäischer
ebene im moment verhandelt wird ist ein
wirksames lieferketten gesetz der eu für
menschen und umwelt weltweit das wäre
ein großer beitrag zu mehr globaler
gerechtigkeit
und ich will und ich will abschließend
noch ein ganz großes problem ansprechen
frau brokers vorhin auch schon
thematisiert das thema finanzen
ich finde es ist wirklich an
scheinheiligkeit nicht zu überbieten
wenn sie sich hier hinstellen und ihren
ehemaligen minister hier über den grünen
klee loben wenn die wahrheit doch ist
dass der haushalt des bmz nach ihrer
finanzplanung in den nächsten jahren
massiv zusammen geschrumpft werden soll
das ist keine seriöse politik das ist
scheinheilig meine damen und herren und
so geht's nicht weiter
liebe politischen gestalten sie
entschuldigung herr diesem buch
gestatten sie einen zwischen frage von
herrn stephan aus der cdu/csu-fraktion
herr kollege vielen dank dass sie die
zwischenfrage zu lassen während sie
bereits zur kenntnis zu nehmen dass die
letzte bundesregierung und der
unionsführung war mit einem
spd-finanzminister heutige bundeskanzler
der diese finanzplanung vorgelegt hat
würden sie außerdem zur kenntnis nehmen
dass sowohl die unions fraktion als auch
damals die spd-fraktion die
entwicklungspolitiker dort den
finanzminister für diesen vorgelegten
finanzplan
kritisiert haben würden sie außerdem zur
kenntnis nehmen dass die jetzige
entwicklungsministerin im kabinett
diesem plan zugestimmt hat und nur
entwicklungsminister müller eine
entsprechende protokoll notiz abgegeben
habe würden sie das bitte zu
interessieren
sie haben das wort dafür dass steffen
hat vielen dank für die frage ich würde
ihnen damit in einem satz antworten wenn
sie mit dem finger auf diese
bundesregierung zeigen dann zeigen
mindestens drei finger auf sie zurück
weil sie waren beteiligt an der letzten
bundesregierung und sie waren
verantwortlich sie haben den zuständigen
entwicklungsminister dazu gestellt meine
damen und herren wir wollen das besser
machen in zukunft vier stellen die
echten bedarf für der partnerländer in
den mittelpunkt klima menschenrechte
biodiversität geschlechtergerechtigkeit
bildung armut orientierung oder kurz
gesagt die globalen nachhaltigkeitsziele
der vereinten nationen das ist unsere
richtschnur damit der nächste
entwicklungspolitische bricht besser
ausfällt vielen dank
die unmik lasse diesen bus war das aus
der fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen und
kurz vor ende seiner rede hat ja noch
eine frage irgendwann ich steh finger
mehr oder weniger beantwortet jetzt gar
new york ist der nächste redner kommt
aus der fdp fraktion und hält jetzt hier
auch seine erste rede wie vorhin schon
mal erwähnt es gibt auch zwei anträge
der afd zu diesem tagesordnungspunkt
unternehmer in mitteldeutschland und
darf mich seit meiner direktwahlen mit
der deutschen entwicklungspolitik
auseinandersetzen das ist zugegeben noch
nicht allzu lange doch was ich hier
bisher beobachten konnte muss bei jedem
vernünftigen bürger grundsätzliche
fragen aufwerfen um was geht es heute
eigentlich
alles was wir hier bisher zum thema
entwicklungspolitik gehört haben ist mit
verlaub eine selbstbeweihräucherung der
alten und neuen bundesregierung
gewürzt mit irrsinnig weltfremden
globalisierung fantasien und linker
klima history meine damen und herren es
ist zeit sich ehrlich zu machen die
deutsche entwicklungspolitik ist an sich
selbst gescheitert
wäre sie so erfolgreich wie es im
entwicklungspolitischen bericht der
bundesregierung im hochglanz format
dargestellt wird so müssten doch nach
über 60 erfolgreichen jahren überflüssig
geworden sein aber genau das gegenteil
ist der fall die ausgaben für
entwicklungshilfe sind weltweit
kontinuierlich angestiegen allein
deutschland hat im jahr 20 20 fast
25 milliarden euro steuergelder dafür
ausgegeben was ist also das ergebnis
ihrer so erfolgreichen
politik man sich um in afghanistan in
mali oder burkina faso wurden die
millennium entwicklungsziele im jahr
2015 erreicht nein wenn diese hoch
gepriesenen 17 nachhaltigkeitsziele der
agent 20 30 zu erreichen sein
und das gibt mittlerweile selbst zu ich
sage ihnen was ergebnisse ihrer politik
ist ergebnis ist ein überbordender
verwaltungsapparat ergebnis ist eine
stadt ist voll finanzierte
entwicklungshilfe industrie mit
sogenannter
zivilgesellschaft und linken endlos
ergebnis ihrer politik ist die
konsequente abwendung vom grundsatz der
hilfe zur selbsthilfe und damit vom kern
der christlichen soziallehre das
ergebnis ist also eine völlige
alleinstellung ihrer eigenen
weltanschauung ganz zur freude einer
dekadenten wohlstands generation den sie
das kleine nutzlose afrika abenteuer
bereitwillig bezahlen aber
bestes beispiel für diese weltanschauung
ist allein schon die überschrift des
berichtes eine welt unsere verantwortung
nein deutschland ist nicht für die welt
verantwortlich und die eine welt gibt es
ohnehin ist deutschland ist in erster
linie für seinen eigenen bürger
verantwortlich so wie jeder andere staat
der erde es auch für sich und seine
bürger ist
angesichts unserer aktuelle
herausforderungen vor denen unser land
und unsere bürger stehen ist es ratsam
wieder zu einer rationalen politik
zurückzukehren also zurück zu kehren zu
einer politik die ganz natürlich eigene
interessen verfolgt und die spechte
betonen dass das verfolgen eigener
interessen eben nicht dem grundgedanken
der entwicklungspolitik widerspricht im
gegenteil eine zusammenarbeit im
gegenseitigen interesse ist näher an der
realität und verspricht mehr erfolg
willen sagen
der bundestag diskutiert über den
entwicklungspolitischen bericht der
bundesregierung und währenddessen sagt
die kollegin die mir redaktionell zur
seite steht beziehungsweise sitzt das
ist der tag der eilmeldung und die will
ich ihnen auch nicht vorenthalten
russland so heißt es eben chance france
press russland kündigt die rückkehr von
panzereinheiten zu stützpunkten an
schauen wir mal wie viel an diesem
rückzug dran ist am pult dieses
christoph hoffmann aus der fdp fraktion
ich empfehle erstmal an den sitzungen
des ausschusses für wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit wirklich teilzunehmen
sich da einzubringen da können sie noch
viel lernen
der entwicklungspolitische bericht zeigt
was entwicklungspolitik leisten kann
aber er zeigt auch wo die defizite
liegen und zwei dinge müssen sich
dringend ändern wir brauchen klare
linien klare ziele statt spontanität und
mangelnder kohärenz und im nächsten hat
ja heute gerade ein solches ziel
vorgegeben und dafür bin ich dankbar
dass wir ein klares ziel hier formuliert
haben die groko hat er ein agenda
surfing betrieben alles was gerade so
moderne war wurde durch gibt durch
getrieben also wir hatten die migrations
krise wir haben die klimakrise wir
hatten die kogit krise da gab es dann
immer spontane initiativen die hinterher
auch sehr publikumswirksam positioniert
worden sind aber das ist doch kein
erfolg unter stetiger wenn sie jetzt
sagen dass die weltweiten erfolge in der
hungerbekämpfung auf einem csu minister
zurückgehen glaube ich das ist schon
ziemlich vermessen
es war letztendlich die globalisierung
dieser welt wo der reichtum insgesamt
gestiegen ist die dazu geführt hat dass
es bessere zustände in diesen ländern
gibt
bei all diesen themen der
entwicklungspolitik ist es klar dass es
im zentrum und armutsbekämpfung geht es
ist dieser elende teufelskreis von
hunger schafft konflikte und konflikte
schaffen hunger und den müssen wir
beenden und das können wir tun wenn wir
es wirklich wollen und hier auch alle
mal zusammen stehen und
deutschland kann das nicht alleine
schaffen deshalb sehen die spontanen
bilateralen ansätze die herr müller so
gepflegt hat nicht der richtige ansatz
sondern müssen uns mehr multilateral
vernetzen mehr zusammenstehen mit der eu
und den internationalen gebern dann
haben wir eine chance die situation
deutlich zu verbessern und
sie haben es gesehen in der rede der
ministerin wir als ampel werden das
silodenken beenden und kohärent handeln
und eben ziele verfolgen und nicht
spontan projekt aktionen durchführen und
publikumswirksam feiern also um die
ministerin hat völlig recht zum beispiel
die frauenförderung ist eine wirkliche
waffe gegen den hunger in dieser welt
und damit ich sie eine waffe die
konflikte zu lösen herr hoffmann
gestatten sie eine zwischenfrage aus der
fdp-fraktion
nein würde ich nicht gerne machen
das zweite was wir ändern müssen wir
müssen mehr strategisch denken und dez
mittel so einsetzen dass sie zu hebeln
werden dass sie zu verstärken werden und
so privates kapital wirklich mobilisiert
werden können meine damen und herren das
ist wirklich entscheidend zu glauben
dass die öffentlichen mittel in einer
art und weise die welt verändern werden
das ist ein irrglaube das wird nie und
nimmer stattfinden dafür sind die
öffentlichen mittel einfach viel zu
gering egal wie groß unser haushalt wird
wir müssen schauen dass die ezb zum
hebel werden dass wir instrumente
installieren mit den ez mitteln wo
private mittel dann entsprechend folgen
und die geopolitischen verschiebungen
auf dieser welt sind dieser tage ja
unglaublich spürbar und deutschland
braucht viele freunde auf der welt ja
sehr viele freunde auf dieser welt
und wir neigen eher dazu und in fein
verästelten innenpolitischen themen
aufzuhalten und denen den vorzug zu
geben meine damen und herren das ist
falsch und das ist nicht gut für unser
land die entwicklungszusammenarbeit wird
oft unterschätzt aber sie ist das
zentrale thema bei politischen
stabilität bei der klimafrage und der
energiefrage hier spielt die
entwicklungszusammenarbeit die
entscheidende rolle und ich glaube da
verdient die entwicklung zusammen heute
mehr aufmerksamkeit im deutschen
bundestag aber auch im bundeshaushalt
und deshalb werden wir dafür kämpfen
dass die ziele die im koalitionsvertrag
verankert sind auch so realisiert werden
christoph hoffmann war das so aus der
fdp fraktion und dem wird jetzt folgen
als nächster redner manuel gasser aus
der spd-fraktion beide übrigens und wie
die allermeisten redner in dieser
debatte mitglieder im ausschuss für
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung aber es gibt noch eine
kurzintervention des abgeordneten
frohnmeyer aus der afg fraktion
herr hoffmann ich muss das schon noch
mal einen haken gerade was die
wertschätzung der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit auch hier im
haus anbelangt wir haben das gestern als
ausschussmitglieder erlebt die fdp
fraktion hatte am anfang auch noch dafür
gestimmt dass wir vormittags unsere
sitzungen durchführen und gestern haben
wir erlebt und es muss ich mal sagen an
der stelle so fair muss man sein mit dem
ramsauer hat es nicht gegeben dass ganze
tagesordnungspunkte abgesetzt werden
mussten oder es zu verschiebungen von 20
bis 30 minuten kam weil er ahnen
überhaupt gar nicht anwesend sein konnte
das ist ihre wertschätzung für die
deutsche entwicklungszusammenarbeit hier
im hause das muss man an der stelle
glaube ich mal ganz klar sagen und dann
zum bericht und dann komme ich auch
gleich zum ende wir haben ja gar nichts
gehört heute wir haben wieder irgendwas
mit feministischer außenpolitik gehört
und solarzellen aufleben hütten und dann
glauben sie sie werden die
lebensverhältnisse der menschen auf dem
afrikanischen guinea
vorhalt entschuldigung dass nike einen
redebeitrag sondern beziehen sie sich
bitte auf die rede von ihrem vorredner
war der klassiker wenn das mache ich
auch sie müssen mich einfach weiter
sprechen lassen dann würde ich das
gleich tun
also herr hoffmann ich muss jetzt mal
fragen werden sich dafür einsetzen dass
die entwicklungszusammenarbeit wieder
den stellenwert hier im haus erhält den
sie verdient wird die fdp dafür sorgen
dass wir ganz normal wieder vormittags
tagen und die funktionsfähigkeit unseres
ausschusses hergestellt wird vielen dank
herr hoffmann möchten sie antworten
das will ich gerne
sie haben gesagt sie müssten jetzt hier
ein haken sie müssen nicht sie haben
gesagt die präsidentin müsste sie jetzt
weiter reden lassen das muss sie nicht
sie verkennen ihre rolle und das zweite
was ich ihnen sagen will wenn sie hierzu
gehört hätten dann haben wir haben ich
genauer skizziert was wir in der ampel
in der entwicklungspolitik gemeinsam
bewerkstelligen werden und sie halten
sich auf mit kleinteiligen geschichten
wie tagesordnungen oder sitzungstermine
vielen dank nächste redner für die spd
fraktion ist manuell gawer den ich auch
zu seiner ersten rede hier im hohen
hause begrüßen
frau präsidentin meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen nach dieser kurzintervention
versuche ich jetzt wieder zur sache zu
kommen denn am ende des tages geht es
glaube ich nicht darum wann die orga
stattfindet sondern es geht um den
entwicklungspolitischen bericht der
bundesregierung darauf kommt es an liebe
kollegen
gerecht und nachhaltig wirtschaften das
ist die zentrale des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhunderts die einbindung in globalen
lieferketten bietet gerade ländern aus
dem globalen süden große chancen für
ihre wirtschaftliche entwicklung jedoch
nur wenn diese integration nach fairen
und sozialen maßstäben gelingt
viele unternehmen verlagern ihre
produktion in entwicklungs und
schwellenländern und verfrachten somit
ihre anfallenden sozial und umweltkosten
dorthin dabei werden milliarden
erwirtschaftet und gleichzeitig menschen
und kinderrechte häufig missachtet
wenn wir weiter so wirtschaften selbst
die schere zwischen arm und reich
weltweit immer weiter auseinander dabei
haben wir uns mit der agenda 20.30 frau
ministerin schulze hat darauf
hingewiesen den nachhaltigkeitszielen
innerhalb der deutschen politik
verpflichtet
liebe kollegen und kolleginnen selbst
wenn wir überteuerte produkte kaufen
heißt es noch lange nicht dass diese
produkte nach fairen arbeitsbedingungen
hergestellt werden produkte wie
beispielsweise kaffee aus brasilien t
aus indien oder weit aus südafrika
werden nicht selten unter missachtung
von menschen und kinderrechten
hergestellt ganz zu schweigen vom
problem der umweltzerstörung
liebe kollegen mehr importieren kaffee
und kakao bohnen und exportieren soziale
ungerechtigkeit wir nehmen hungerlöhne
schlechte arbeitsbedingungen und die
ausbeutung von menschen jeden tag an der
supermarktkette in kauf und das ist
jetzt ganz wichtig und das ist mir
besonders wichtig dass es keine
konsumentinnen kritik denn das ist
politisches handeln was die
erforderlichen liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
aber das gute ist dass viele menschen
uns dabei unterstützen denn bei vielen
lecks das interesse daran herauszufinden
wo das kaffeepulver innerhalb der
kaffeemaschine herkommt und die
nachfrage nach nachhaltigen und fairen
hergestellten produkten nimmt weiter zu
und das erhöht nämlich auch automatisch
den druck auf die unternehmen die
verantwortung und bedingungen ihrer
lieferketten klar zu übernehmen und
darzustellen
gesetzgeberisches handeln ist
erforderlich und wir kommen als politik
nicht umhin faire bedingungen entlang
der gesamten lieferkette zu kämpfen
und wie alle glaube ich hier in diesem
hause sich eigentlich sind herrscht bei
uns in europa der konsens dass unsere
soziale marktwirtschaft zu standards der
menschenrechte der umweltfragen und
arbeitsbedingungen umfasst und genau aus
dieser überzeugung heraus haben wir als
bundesrepublik mit dem lieferketten
gesetz eine vorreiterrolle bei der
durchsetzung fairer und nachhaltiger
globaler lieferketten auf europäischer
ebene übernommen herzlichen dank an
dieser stelle auch an alle initiativen
angy aus an alle aus der
zivilgesellschaft die das ermöglicht
haben und auf ganz besonders an den
spd-geführten teil der letzten großen
koalition der sich durch große sache ich
mal schwierigkeiten und auch durch
großen kampf der union dagegen
durchsetzen musste und das hinbekommen
hat das land an dieser stelle
peinlich wäre ich von der afg das ist
immer ein gutes zeichen dass die rede
nicht ganz so schlecht sein kann wir
werden uns auch für einige weite
regelung einsetzen wir unterstützen ein
wirksames eu lieferketten gesetz das auf
menschenrechtsprinzipien basiert und
gleichzeitig kleinere und mittlere
unternehmen nicht überfordert
[Applaus]
es macht spaß verbindliche regelung im
globalen lieferkette existenzsichernde
löhne die rechte arbeitsbedingungen und
umweltverträglichkeit sind das fundament
deutsche entwicklungszusammenarbeit und
wer dagegen verstößt verliert seinen
anspruch auf staatliche zuwendungen und
im extremfall auch sein marktzugang und
das ist auch gut so
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren das
ziel ist die gesamte lieferkette
transparenz rückverfolgbar sowie fair
und nachhaltig zu gestalten von der
produktion über den handel bis hin zum
verkauf um geschäft an dieser stelle
vielen dank dass ich meine erste rede in
diesem hohen haus halten durfte das ist
ziemlich imposant ich danke der
ministerin schulze dass das thema des
gerechten und nachhaltigen wirtschaftens
ein großer teil des
entwicklungspolitischen berichtes ist
und auf bessere zusammenarbeit vielen
dank
das war manuel gabe auf die
zwischenbemerkung wie er vorhin gemacht
hatte bevor er einen schluck wasser
getrunken hat war macht ja spaß und wenn
das nicht die zwischenbemerkungen des
tages ist dann weiß ich auch mit nicolas
zippelius der nächste redner in dieser
debatte in der es den
entwicklungspolitischen bericht der
bundesregierung geht aber auch um
entwicklungspolitik im allgemeinen und
besonderes und wie gerade im hintergrund
hören
bundestagspräsidentin in den bars sagt
auch nicolas leoz hat hier seine erste
rede und der kommt aus der
unionsfraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren die verwirklichung des
fairen handels zwischen industrie
schwellen und entwicklungsländern gehört
zu einer der vier säulen der deutschen
entwicklungspolitik fairer handel
ist hier weil das entscheidende
stichwort
gemeinsam mit anderen staaten
entwicklungspolitischen partnern und der
wirtschaft wollen wir daran arbeiten
nachhaltige globale liefer und
wertschöpfungsketten verstärkt zu
verbessern
nachhaltigkeit und menschenrechte als
unabdingbare grundpfeiler des globalen
handels weiter zu verankern und somit
eine gerechte sowie nachhaltige
globalisierung weiter auf den weg zu
bringen
das wollen wir als cdu csu
dafür haben wir als union gemeinsam mit
dem ehemaligen bundesminister für
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung gerd müller erfolgreich in
den vergangenen jahren die
entscheidenden weichen gestellt und
dafür werden wir uns auch in dieser
legislatur weiter stark machen
und die erfolge aus der vergangenen
legislaturperiode
die werden im entwicklungspolitischen
bericht der bundesregierung sichtbar und
die können sich sehen lassen im juni
2021 wurde unter der alten
bundesregierung das lieferketten
sorgfaltspflichten gesetz beschlossen
die gewährleistung und sicherstellung
von menschenrechten von sozial- und
umweltstandards innerhalb der globalen
liefer und wertschöpfungsketten ist ein
anliegen anliegen für welches wir uns
als union auch auf eu ebene weiter stark
machen werden
und es bringt jetzt auch nichts liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen von der
ampelkoalition ist so darzustellen als
wir uns hier einen völlig neuen
politischen grundsatz präsentieren das
bereits bestehende lieferketten
sorgfaltspflichten gesetzt ist eine
wichtige blaupause für eine europäische
richtlinie zu menschenrechtlichen
sorgfaltspflichten von unternehmen und
es zeigt dass die neue bundesregierung
auf eine richtungsweisende deutsche
entwicklungspolitik aufbauen kann und
dafür haben wir als union gesorgt
und das war nur ein beispiel der
geleisteten arbeit in den letzten jahren
das staatliche textil siegel grüner
knopf soll und wird nachhaltigen konsum
weiter prägen damit wurde ein zentrales
ziel der vereinten nationen zur
nachhaltigen entwicklung umgesetzt und
wie im entwicklungspolitischen bericht
der bundesregierung geschrieben hat sich
die zahl der teilnehmenden unternehmen
mit insgesamt 78 seit programm
einführung vor fast zwei jahren ungefähr
verdreifacht und 100 weitere unternehmen
haben das siegel bereits beantragt und
das ist ein gutes zeichen und das ist
ein wichtiges zeichen meine damen und
herren
und nicht zu vergessen die gründung des
weltnaturerbes im jahr 2021 dieser fonds
wird bis zum jahr 2030 zur weltgrößten
naturschutzstiftung heranwachsen das bmz
unterstützt dabei 660 schutzgebiete mit
einer größe von zwei millionen
quadratkilometern beteiligt sich am
schutz von 130 millionen hektar wald
alles in allem zeigt der bericht frau
ministerin wo sie an die erfolgreiche
arbeit ihres vorgängers vorgängers
anknüpfen können und auch anknüpfen
sollten
und damit kommen wir zu ihren
hausaufgaben frau ministerin im
koalitionsvertrag herrscht leider
gähnende leere wenn es um das engagement
der wirtschaft in entwicklungsländern
geht und wenn es darum geht wie dieses
und engagement unterstützt werden soll
und es ist daher von enormer bedeutung
dass das eu projekt global gateway von
der bundesregierung nach kräften
protestiert wird bis zu 300 milliarden
euro sollen dabei von mitgliedstaaten
und institutionen mobilisiert werden
geld das hilft wichtige projekte der
privatwirtschaft in entwicklungsländern
abzusichern und wie wichtig die
unternehmerische ebene für
entwicklungspolitik ist hat doch gestern
erst wieder das unternehmen bei und hat
gezeigt dass schlüsselfertige mobile
produktionsanlagen nach afrika bringen
möchte um vor ort
rm rm stoffe herstellen zu können und
wenn rot-grün unternehmerisches
engagement immer nur als teil des
problems sieht dann bitte ich dann
bitten wir doch wenigstens die
kolleginnen und kollegen von der fdp
dieses engagement als wichtigen teil der
lösung anzuerkennen
was die öffentlichen bildungsausgaben
deutschlands betrifft haben sie
forschung zu ihrer letzten rede von
einem starken zeichen koalitionsvertrag
gesprochen das ist aber nicht mal
ansatzweise ihr verdienst ihr vorgänger
frau ministerin hat ihnen diese optimale
ausgangslage ermöglicht in deutschland
hat bereits 2020 die internationale
messgröße von mindestens 0,7 prozent des
bruttonationaleinkommens für öffentliche
entwicklungsleistungen aufzuwenden
erreicht das jetzt zum beispiel die
grünen das kritisch kritisieren dass
nicht mehr dabei heraus kommen können
okay aber dass die spd dabei mit
klatschen das ist wirklich der größte
hohen und da kann man wirklich nur den
kopf schütteln
und vom minister wird das hätte übrigens
noch mehr werden können auch
mittelfristig wenn der damalige
finanzminister und ihr parteikollege
olaf scholz eine erhöhung der ausgaben
keinen riegel vorgeschoben hätte und
sich mit fremden federn schmücken wenn
es passt aber ansonsten die schuld nur
bei anderen suchen das lassen wir ihn
mit sicherheit nicht durchgehen lassen
sie sich das von uns gesagt sein
frau ministerin sie haben viel zu tun
wir als cdu csu bundestagsfraktion
werden ihnen gerne ein kompass für
erfolgreiche politik im bereich der
wirtschaftlichen zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung sein trauen sie sich
herzlichen dank
sagt nicholas zippelius der der
drittletzte redner in dieser debatte war
in richtung svenja schulze und der
abgeordnete pius hat wiederholt und
viele redner vor ihm auch gerd müller
angesprochen den vorgänger von svenja
schulze der ja mit einem ganz haltigen
ganzheitlichen und einem nachhaltigen
ansatz in der entwicklungspolitik
tatsächlich auch viele neue wege
gegangen ist die oftmals auch die
zustimmung von spd und grünen durchaus
hatten in deborah döring es die nächste
rednerin sprecherin für wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit und entwicklung der
fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen
bericht hochgelobten reform war
entwicklungspolitik strategischer
effizienter und wirksamer einzusetzen
ob dies gelungen ist darüber lässt sich
ein anderer seite gerne mal diskutieren
auf jeden fall lässt sich aber
festhalten dass die strategische
komponente in müllers sinne umgesetzt
wurde leider denn entwicklungspolitik
stand in den letzten jahren immer mehr
im dienste von geopolitischen und
innenpolitischen interessen deutschlands
das sehen wir zum beispiel an der neuen
länder ist während neun sogenannte ließ
development countries einfach raus
gestrichen wurden bleiben vor allem die
länder die auf der flucht und migrations
routen nach europa liegen als partner
vorhanden ungeachtet ihrer oftmals
autoritäre regierungsführung
menschenrechte kriterien oder bedürftig
keiten spielten in vielen fällen und
scheint eher eine untergeordnete rolle
das liebe kolleginnen kollegen
widerspricht nicht nur den eigenen
formulierten ansprüchen sondern ist das
gegenteil einer entwicklungspolitik die
effizient und wirksam für globale
gerechtigkeit kämpft
was passiert wenn deutsche
entwicklungspolitik probleme erzeugt die
es ohne sie nicht gäbe sieht man
beispielsweise im niger das bmz
unterstützt das land bei der ich zitiere
gestaltung einer kohärenten
migrationspolitik und lobt die schaffung
von kurzfristigen jobs als flucht
ursachenbekämpfung
wanderbewegungen im niger sind seit
jahrhunderten teil der
gesellschaftlichen normalität dort die
lokale wirtschaft lebt von
dienstleistungen für migrantinnen
2015 wurde dann die migration durch den
niger von der eu als problem
gebrandmarkt geld floss an die
regierungen um die migration zu
kontrollieren mit verheerenden folgen
für die migrantinnen und massiven
jobverlusten für die menschen vor ort
wenn wir fluchtursachen und nicht die
flüchtenden bekämpfen wollen dann müssen
wir anfangen die strukturellen ursachen
von armut und ungleichheit ranzugehen
und wir müssen endlich die bedürfnisse
die rechte und den schutz von
geflüchteten menschen voranstellen
ich bin sehr froh dass wir klar im
koalitionsvertrag formuliert haben
entwicklungszusammenarbeit darf nicht
davon abhängig gemacht werden ob ein
land in der migrations eindämmung
kooperiert stattdessen müssen wir
sichere und legale fluchtwege geschaffen
humanitäre visa ermöglichen und das
resettlement programm ausweiten und ich
freue mich darauf genau das in vier
jahren im weißbuch der
entwicklungspolitik lesen zu dürfen
die
regierungsfraktionen 90 die grünen da in
dieser legislaturperiode sprecherin für
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
entwicklung und damit sein biologischer
weise weil sie wie vor letzte rednerin
beim letzten kramer die ja wie cognac
aus der spd fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren knapp ein
zehntel der bevölkerung auf dem
afrikanischen kontinent ist derzeit
vollständig gegen korona geimpft
das ist besorgniserregend denn diese
pandemie mit siegen wir weltweit oder
gar nicht
die große koalition hat in der letzten
legislaturperiode bereits mit
deutschland fortschritte erreicht um den
herausforderungen unserer zeit zu
begegnen
ich nehme hier nur drei beispiele
das bmz hat jährlich rund zwei
milliarden euro in
ernährungssicherung landwirtschaft und
ländliche entwicklung investiert seit 20
20 deutschland ein weltweites corona
sofortprogramm von sage und schreibe 4,7
milliarden euro um und lieber eine
milliarde euro werden jährlich
zusätzlich in globale gesundheit
investiert die bundesregierung ist der
zweitgrößte geber zu corona so kovats
initiative für die globale impfstoff
gerechtigkeit die gegründet wurde für
den aufbau der corona im speziell in
afrika wo dann rund 500 millionen euro
investiert
der aufbau der lokalen in koproduktion
ist entscheidend um den globalen süden
unabhängiger von impfstoff importen zu
machen die bundesregierung unterstützt
deshalb vier afrikanischen ländern unter
anderem das institut pasteur in dakar in
senegal ein aufbau einer eigenen
produktion
das ist ein schritt um den afrikanischen
kontinent als souveränen qualifizierten
akteur wahrnehmen in der aktuelle
pandemie hat sich seit was der kontinent
als effektive pandemie manager bewiesen
besonders das regionale zusammenarbeit
und initiativen der spanischen union
so wurden unter anderem
eigene seuchenschutzbehörde und eine
gemeinsame digitale
beschaffungsplattform für medizinischen
ausrüstung co-gründer dies zeigt den
kontinent als fähigen partner in der
entwicklungszusammenarbeit und das nimmt
uns in die verantwortung denn auch wir
müssen uns neu ausrichten
hin zu einer entwickelt zusammenarbeit
auf augenhöhe einer globalen
strukturpolitik war eine sehr verdammt
haben
aktuell wird uns die pandemie in der
erreichung der agenda 20.30 um den
nachhaltigkeitszielen denn es hieß er
noch zurück wir sollten daher die zeit
nach der pandemie nutzen um eigene neuen
weg der nachhaltigen entwicklung
einzuschlagen die aktuellen
herausforderungen des klimawandels eine
globale pandemien können wir nur
gemeinsam bewältigen hier können ganz im
sinne der vernetzten ansatz dass
investitionen in internationale
forschung hilfreich seien auch
die potenziale digitalisierung sollten
wir nutzen um beispielsweise den
universellen zugang zu
gesundheitsversorgung ermöglichen an
diesem punkt können wir von unseren
partnern auf dem afrikanischen kontinent
lernen fest steht die herausforderungen
des klimawandels
globaler pandemien können wir nur
gemeinsam bewältigen diese ziele der
agenda fand sich 30 müssen unsere
richtschnur für die entwicklungspolitik
der kommenden jahren sein packen wir das
an
[Applaus]
vielen dank ich schließe die aussprache
und das bedeutete der
anträge die aus der fraktion hier
vorliegen als auch der bericht der
bundesregierung überwiesen werden also
im zuständigen ausschuss weiter
diskutiert und werden in den kommenden
wochen und das gibt uns die gelegenheit
schon mal zu schauen auf die nächsten
tagesordnungspunkt der bärbel bas hier
gleich aufrufen wird es geht nämlich um
die haltung des westens zu zur politik
russlands dazu liegen drei anträge vor
nämlich einmal aus der unionsfraktion
die setzt vor allem auf geschlossenheit
des westens gegenüber russland die
antrag antrag der linken setzt darauf
einer
deeskalation absoluten vorrang zu geben
geben und deswegen auch eine die
bundeswehr soldaten nach litauen leben
nicht zu entsenden und dann gibt es noch
den antrag aus der afg formation
vertrauen schaffen sicherheit
garantieren die afg betont dass es
gespräche auf allen ebenen und in allen
gesprächs formaten für eine friedliche
lösung des konflikts geben müssen also
im grunde das was die bundesregierung ja
schon seit mehreren wochen versucht
unter anderem manifestiert durch die
besucher des bundeskanzlers in moskau
aber auch in kiel die zahlreichen reihen
der der bundesaußenminister in annalena
baerbock die jetzt auch auf der
regierungsbank platz genommen hat und
der erste redner in dieser aussprache
geht johann david wadephul sein
stellvertretender vorsitzender der
unionsfraktion
als russland die krim rechtswidrig
annektierte und in einem hybriden ansatz
bewaffnete konflikte im osten der kleine
initiierte die bis heute andauern nicht
vorstellen können russische streitkräfte
in einem ausmaß dass sie ohne weiteres
in der lage sind nach wie vor
bedauerlicherweise
die ukraine zu überfallen dort eine
militärische invasion durchzuführen
befinden sich an den grenzen dieses
zweitgrößten europäischen
landes das modell einer ukraine die
demokratisch parlamentarisch
funktioniert der das freie presse und
freie gerichte gibt wird von der
russischen führung offensichtlich als
bedrohung angesehen
friedrich merz hatte in der letzten
debatte hier schon darauf hingewiesen
welche entwicklung ist in russland
gegeben habt nachdem wladimir putin hier
noch 2001 im westen eine zusammenarbeit
anbot die wir auch nicht vollständig
angenommen haben hat er 2008 auf der
münchner sicherheitskonferenz
dem zusammenbruch der sowjetunion als
die größte katastrophe des zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts bezeichnet hier sieht man
offenkundig die motive der russischen
führung das ist nur eine erklärung keine
legitimierung und keine legalisierung
des russischen vorgehens was wir in und
um die ukraine sehen einem solchen
vorgehen was russland seit 2014 in der
ukraine zeigt und was es jetzt wieder an
droht durch diese truppen massierung
muss sich die freie welt entgegen stehen
hier muss deutschland gemeinsam mit
unseren europäischen partnern den
vereinigten staaten für frieden für die
einhaltung der regelbasierten ordnung
und für die internationale rechtsordnung
einstehen
in diesem
sinne hat die bundesregierung in den
letzten wochen gehandelt danke der
außenministerin ausdrücklich auch für
ihre reise an die kontakt linie für ihre
reise nach kiew für ihre klaren aussagen
dort ich danke auch den bundeskanzler
der jetzt in kiew und dann auch im
beisein von vladimir putin nach einem
ausführlichen gespräch klargemacht hat
dass deutschland dieses verhalten nicht
akzeptiert dass wir gemeinsam
geschlossen mit den vereinigten staaten
mit unseren europäischen partnern wird
die baltischen staaten mit polen mit
allen anrainerstaaten dort
entgegenstehen dieses
verantwortungsvolle handeln der
bundesregierung unterstützt die cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion
wir haben allerdings zu der form des
vorgehens und zu ihrer kommunikation
anmerkungen zu machen und die erste
anmerkung ist das fehlen des
bundeskanzlers in dieser debatte
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren es
droht nicht weniger als krieg und der
bundeskanzler zu recht in moskau gesagt
es sei die verdammte pflicht politisch
dagegen zu arbeiten aber ich sage auch
in einer parlamentarischen demokratie
wieder bundesrecht deutschland ist es
die erste pflicht des bundeskanzlers der
bund deutschland seine politik in dieser
krise hier zu erläutern hier vor dem
deutschen bundestag wo sind sie herr
scholz
hat er deutlich gemacht dass er die
verfassungsordnung kennt und darauf
hingewiesen dass er und nicht gerhard
schröder der aktuelle bundeskanzler ist
aber unser staat verfassungsrecht regelt
ja nicht nur die exekutive und deren
funktionsweise sondern das parlament
ist der erste ort wo politik erklärt
gerechtfertigt und dargelegt werden muss
ich muss sagen begrüße sehr dass die
frau bundesministerin jetzt hier ist
aber das fehlen des bundeskanzlers ist
nicht zu rechtfertigen und er hätte auch
früher klare worte finden müssen
ich danke an dieser stelle ausdrücklich
bundespräsident frank walter steinmeier
für seine rede auf der bundesrat
er hat klar gemacht und das wäre die
aufgabe des bundeskanzlers gewesen wo
deutschland steht
der bundeskanzler ist unklar geblieben
bedauerlicherweise an der seite eines
amerikanischen präsidenten der wie kein
anderer in amerika und angefochten
insbesondere durch die republikaner die
derzeit auch wieder vor dem sprung
stehen mehr einfluss zu bekommen in den
usa der wie kein anderer an der seite
europas steht und betont er will
gemeinsam mit deutschland politik machen
aber sich dorthin zu stellen und es dem
amerikanischen präsidenten zu überlassen
zu klären das nord stream 2 zum
sanktionspaket natürlich dazugehört
das war eine situation
das war schon demütigend für den
deutschen bundeskanzler und das hat das
hat den amerikanischen präsidenten der
an unserer seite steht in amerika in
zusätzliche politische schwierigkeiten
gebracht die wir noch einmal bereuen
könnte meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren das war ein großer fehler
und das verhalten gegenüber der ukraine
ist auf rechtfertigungsbedarf
natürlich gehört deutschland nicht zu
den ersten ländern die waffen liefern
das ist doch vollkommen klar dass man
dort zurückhaltung übt ist gute deutsche
tradition aber verstehen wir nicht wie
das für die ukraine wirken muss die sich
einer derartigen militärischen
aggression gegenüber stehen das das
erste was wir ankündigen lazarette sind
verstehen wir nicht dass das in der
ukraine fast als zynisch verstanden wird
und wenn wir dann noch unsere nato
partnern wie den ersten in den arm
fallen die ein paar veraltete artillerie
systeme liefern wollen meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren das ist keine
position der solidarität mit der ukraine
und das war auch ein großer und das
bleibt ein großer fehler der
bundesregierung
und
vize-kanzler arbeit muss man sagen wer
als parteivorsitzender defensivwaffen
für richtig hält der darf sich wenn er
dann ein staatsamt haben hat nicht ein
schweigegelübde auferlegen das passt
nicht zu seinem politischen anspruch den
wir von ihnen kennen der bundeskanzler
hat zu recht gesagt die souveränität der
ukraine ist unantastbar aber auch die
entscheidung der ukraine und des
bündnisses selber irgendwann über einen
eintritt der ukraine in die nato zu
entscheiden muss unantastbar bleiben
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das sage
ich nicht unbedingt auf die ukraine das
steht nicht auf der tagesordnung das
sage ich auch komme aus
schleswig-holstein ostseeanrainer mit
blick auf schweden und finnland wird
dürfen und von russland nicht
vorschreiben lassen wer sich unseren
defensiven friedlichen bündnissen
anschließt das muss klare deutsche
position sein
und ein wort zu russland abschließend
wird durch märz hat öffentlich
richtigerweise gesagt russland ist nicht
unser feind das glaube ich verstehen wir
auch alle hier so insbesonders russische
volk steht uns eher nahe aufgrund einer
langen historie und langen kulturellen
beziehungen durch den letzten krieg hat
deutschland eine besondere verantwortung
dass das russische volk nicht erneut in
kriegerische handlungen verstrickt wird
aber auch das ukrainische volk denn dort
haben die schlimmsten kriegshandlungen
der deutschen wehrmacht im zweiten
weltkrieg stattgefunden wir müssen in
der lage sein zwischen den russischen
volk und denjenigen die die führung dort
haben einer kleptokraten clique zu
unterscheiden wir stehen an der seite
des russischen volkes wir sind ein
freund russlands und gerade deutschland
bei aller realpolitik die natürlich
verlangt mit der regierung zu verhandeln
muss beachten wir haben viel schuld auf
uns geladen in russland und wir sind dem
russischen volk und dem ukrainischen
volk verpflichtet jeden einsatz für
frieden in dieser region zu leisten
herzlichen dank für die aufmerksam
die johann wadephul stellvertretender
vorsitzender der unions-fraktion
vermisst den bundeskanzler in dieser
debatte im deutschen bundestag zur
haltung des westens zur politik
russlands
bundestagspräsidentin was begrüßt den
ukrainischen botschafter in dieser
sekunde mal gucken ob die kolleginnen
und kollegen an den kameras in gleich
noch einfangen ich wollte sagen johann
wadephul vermisst den kanzler in der
debatte an erkennt allerdings die
aktivitäten und gespräche der
bundesregierung und spricht von einem
verantwortungsvollen handeln der nächste
redner kommt wie johann wadephul aus
schleswig holstein ist ralf stegner dem
wir seit vielen jahren in der politik
kennen und hält hier trotzdem seine
erste rede im bundestag
dabei sein durfte und auch nicht zur
senkung des alters schmerz in diesem
hause beitrage ist es meine erste rede
als mitglied des deutschen bundestags
das ist für mich eine große ehre und
dann geht es gleich um den frieden in
europa neben der kommune krise steht
unsere koalition vor einer ersten großen
bewährungsprobe
der massive russische militär aufmarsch
ukrainische grenzen und die spannung in
den letzten wochen bedrohen den frieden
in einer weise die kaum einer von uns
für möglichkeiten hätte und in dieser
situation kommt die neue
oppositionsfraktion mit einem antrag der
herr der mich dann doch wieder in die
user zeiten zurück führt das was sie
zusammen geschrieben haben in ihrem
papier werde kollegin kollegen von der
union ist der retro sound alle wege
führen nach moskau da passt es ins bild
wenn der kollege plus und so
ministerpräsident manuela schwesig
diffamiert nur weil sie seine meinung
nicht teilt ist für ihn nicht nur noch
die vaterlandslose gesellen in dem
antrag wenn man auf ihren antrag wenn da
nicht obendrauf zwanzigster wahlperiode
stehen würde herr oppositionsführer
könnte man meinen es stammt aus ihrer
ersten amtszeit was da steht ich will
einen satz daraus zitieren den sie aber
nicht an die bundesregierung richten
sollten sondern an sich selbst der
nämlich heiß ich fordere sie auf ihrer
gefährlichen schläger kosten der
außenpolitik zu beenden der bayerische
ministerpräsident hat sich nämlich ganz
anders geäußert als sie das in ihrem
gemeinsamen antrag von cdu und csu hier
eingebracht haben aber bei herrn söder
ist ja wahrscheinlich der usc etwas
gerade gilt was seine position angeht
nun mag man ihn lieber kollege wadephul
ihre rollen findung zugute halten aber
wenn sie gestern mit uns gegen
waffenlieferungen heute für waffen
liefern sind wofür sind sie dann
eigentlich morgen und ich muss ihnen
ehrlich sagen wenn es um krieg und
frieden geht ist solche schaukelpolitik
gefährlich zum glueck sitzen wieder herr
merz
nachher bilder im haushalt den abend im
kanzleramt von olaf scholz und annalena
baerbock und das ist gut so
gute außenpolitik war auch
verlässlichkeit disziplinen und ein
felsenfest das wertefundament genau das
haben der bundeskanzler und sie frau
außenministerin in den letzten wochen in
kirchen moskau brüssel washington
vorzüglich bewiesen herzlichen dank
dafür übrigens der bundeskanzlers
entschuldigt weil er die baltischen
staaten gerade informiert über seine
gespräche in moskau nicht hörten dann
einigkeit der alliierten zurückhaltung
bei der f kommunikation und geduld wird
demokratie übersetzung professionalität
gehört es auch dazu dass diplomatie
nicht in interviews betrieben wird und
hinter verschlossenen türen die
schachspieler unter ihnen sollten wir
uns wissen wer die nächsten fünf züge
vorher an können nicht mehr verliert
wahrscheinlich die partie das ist nicht
schlau das war ein ja aber nicht nur
bundeskanzler scholz hat im sinne einer
werte basierten und realitätsbezogen
außen und sicherheitspolitik genau das
richtige gesagt für uns in deutschland
und europa kann es nachhaltige
sicherheit nicht gegen russland soll nur
mit russland geben entsprechend hatte
übrigens auch der französische
staatspräsident geäußert im
koalitionsvertrag heißt es eine
konsistente europäische politik
gegenüber russland muss die
unterschiedlichen positionen von
bedrohungen einbeziehen rolf mützenich
hat recht man muss die russischen
positionen nicht teilen um diese
perspektiven nachvollziehen zu können
natürlich haben sich die verhältnisse
geändert gegenüber der ostpolitik von
willy brandt und walter scheel was ich
aber nicht geändert hat seine geschichte
und geografie in den letzten tagen war
auch von den richtigen lehren die rede
die wir zu ziehen hätten deutschland hat
den zweiten weltkrieg angezettelt halb
europa verwüstet und war verantwortlich
für das monströse verbrechen des
holocaust mit millionen von opfern in
polen russland der ukraine und den
vielen anderen nach 1945 wurden wir
wieder in die völkerfamilie aufgenommen
und wir haben wie kein anderes land von
frieden in europa profitiert natürlich
müssen wir verantwortung versicherten
frieden übernehmen aber das kann nicht
heißen dass deutschland waffenlieferant
in krisengebiete wird meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren nein
deutschland hat eine andere rolle wir
müssen mehr als jeder andere für frieden
kämpfen wir müssen hier mehr als jeder
andere die ukraine wirtschaftlich
unterstützen wir müssen mehr als jeder
andere film liefert über rost ze bis zum
ende alles aber auch wirklich alles
dafür tun dass die diplomatie erfolg hat
das heißt ausgleich berechtigter
interessen auf der basis von
menschenrechten demokratie souveränität
und territoriale integrität der staaten
europas die bundesregierung handelt
geeint und im einklang mit unserer
verbündeten joe biden hat bei der
pressekonferenz in washington gesagt
dass es keinerlei zweifel an der
zuverlässigkeit der deutschen
bundesregierung geben was sagte
oppositionsführer das zeige die zweifel
in der deutschen bundesregierung ich
bewundere dialektischen fähigkeiten der
kollege merz will gar nicht wissen was
sie gesagt hat wir vermeiden dass nicht
erwähnt hätte wahrscheinlich das
gegenteil das ist doch klar sollte es zu
einer militärischen eskalation kommen
müsste russland einen hohen preis zahlen
dann würden die westlichen alliierten
gemeinsamen schnellen geeint und handeln
aber bevor nichts mehr geht heißt es
auch für uns immer wieder lieber 100
stunden umsonst verhandeln als einige
minuten schießen das hat übrigens ein
kluger sozialdemokratische altkanzler
gesagt meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren
bundeskanzler olaf scholz hat in moskau
zur frage einer nato mitgliedschaft der
ukraine betont diese frage stehe auf
absehbare zeit nicht auf der
tagesordnung und es geht darum
pragmatische lösung zu finden die beide
seiten tragen können ohne die grundsätze
aufzugeben so hat es schon auf kennedy
klugerweise der kuba krise gehalten das
war die logik der ostpolitik und das
gilt auch heute wenn es um frieden und
krieg in europa geht den antrag der
union werden wir ablehnen ja lieber olaf
scholz ist es unsere verdammte pflicht
für den frieden einzutreten oder welches
ihr amtsvorgänger willy brandt
formuliert hat der frieden ist nicht
alles aber ohne frieden ist alles nichts
ralf stegner war das mit seiner ersten
rede im deutschen bundestag
wo der hat sich erhalten in der debatte
in der es geht um die haltung des
westens zur politik groß wieder einmal
antreten da vor um 11 uhr den wahlgang
schließen also sollte jemand hier noch
im raum sein oder im hause dann
schnell
und der wahlgang beschäftigt sich mit
dem sondergremium zum
stabilisierungsmechanismus gesetz
dass man nochmal der hinweis eben von
bundestagspräsident in bars alexander
gauland ist auf dem weg zum pult
früher mal in der letzten
legislaturperiode vorsitzender co
vorsitzender der fdp fraktion jetzt
mitglied im auswärtigen ausschuss
frau präsidentin meine damen und herren
stellen wir uns einmal vor wir schreiben
das jahr 2040 und kanada hätte aus
wirtschaftlichen gründen einer
annäherung an china vollzogen und sei
bereit eine militär konvention
abzuschließen und der chinesischen
flotte eine basis auf neue kunden zur
verfügung zu stellen wäre die usa noch
eine großmacht würde sie die monroe
doktrin aufrufen und deutlich machen
dass eine fremde macht auf dem
amerikanischen kontinent mit den
sicherheitsinteressen der usa und
vereinbar ist
wahrscheinlich würde china die usa
darauf hinweisen dass kanada souverän
und frei sei die wahl seiner
militärbündnisse selbst zu bestimmen und
china nur friedliche absichten hege
großen eindruck würde dieses argument in
amerika wohl kaum machen denn ist das
eine nach dem völkerrecht ein
theoretisches recht zu haben und das
andere in einer staaten ordnung wie sie
nun einmal ist und auch bleiben wird
seinen platz mit klugheit zu behaupten
auch wenn uns das ungerecht scheint
malta und china sind nun einmal nicht
gleich von gewicht und macht und daher
ist es für malta notwendiger als für
china seine außenbeziehungen möglichst
geschmeidig zu gestalten dazu gehört
eben auch
mächtigen nachbarn nicht unnötig zu
reizen
die ukraine ist für russland kein
x-beliebiges land sondern teil einer
gemeinsamen vergangenheit
wurzeln in einer gemeinsamen identität
und auch geopolitisch ist oder besser in
fremder oder gar feindlicher hand für
russland nur schwer erträglich ist es
doch das unersetzliche tor für den
handel mit dem mittelmeerraum es geht
hier nicht um werte oder ideologie oder
regierungsform sondern um interessen es
geht um geopolitik was haben wir
deutschen lager verlernt deshalb wäre es
klug lösungen zu finden die für die
großmacht russland annehmbar und für die
ukraine akzeptabel sind
eine nato-mitgliedschaft dieses landes
ist es nicht wohl aber ein wie auch
immer garantierter neutraler status wie
in unterschiedlicher weise finnland und
österreich genießen
auch in der außenpolitik
kann manchmal ein weniger an mehr sein
und eine gesicherte existenz zwischen
den fronten
heilsamer als ein unendlicher konflikt
ja die ukraine hat das recht ihre
bündnisse frei zu wählen doch wie sie da
von dem angesicht ihrer nachbarn
gebrauch macht
entscheidet über erfolg und misserfolg
des noch jungen staatswesens
deshalb sollte der westen alles
vermeiden diese krise zum instrument
eines billigen triumph über russland zu
machen und der ukraine dringend ab
geopolitisch teil des westens zu werden
auf dauer ist
eine europäische friedensordnung nur mit
russland und niemals gegen seine
interessen zu verwirklichen den
cdu-antrag werden wir deshalb natürlich
ablehnen der antrag der linken werden
wir uns enthalten denn er enthält
wichtige elemente ich bedanke mich
alexander gauland war das für die fdp
fraktion und im verkehr in der
stahlbranche mit ihrer zweiten rede
heute vormittag im deutschen bundestag
sie ist ja stellvertretende vorsitzende
der fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen für
die fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen
agnieszka broker
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen vor 20 jahren
am 8 februar 2002 lief in der tagesschau
folgende meldung ich zitiere mit
erlaubnis der präsidentin präsident
putin lob bei einem treffen cdu-chefin
merkel die guten deutsch russischen
beziehungen für einen beitritt russlands
zur nato sei die zeit nicht reif
was heutiger sicht erscheint es alles so
unfassbar weit weg viel weiter weg als
20 jahre denn in diesen tagen müssen wir
uns ernsthaft die frage stellen ob der
gleiche wladimir putin kurz davor ist
ein befehl zu einem militärischen
großangriff auf unsere freunde in der
ukraine zu geben ein befehl da viele
verletzte und tote zur folge hätte und
da wird das internationale recht sehr
schnell nicht theoretisch sondern sehr
konkret ein solcher angriff er wäre aber
auch eine attacke auf unsere gemeinsam
vereinbarte friedensordnung auf unserem
gemeinsamen kontinent wenn wir jetzt
aber zurück schauen was in diesen 20
jahren passiert dann gehört sicherlich
auch die selbstkritische frage dazu ob
nicht auch von seiten der europäischen
staaten der usa der nato chancen
versäumt und fehler begangen wird war es
immer wichtig wie wir auf russische
gesprächsangebote reagiert haben haben
wir sie vielleicht manchmal zu früh ab
getan weiß klug als präsident obama
russland als regionalmacht verspottet
hat und hat uns der streit um die
raketenabwehr am ende unterm strich
wirklich mehr sicherheit gebracht aber
meine damen und herren nichts davon
rechtfertigt auch nur ansatzweise das
was wir in den letzten jahren beobachten
müssen den völkerrechts bruch mit der
annexion der krim den krieg in der ost
ukraine und nun die aufrüstung und
truppen konzentration in belarus im
schwarzen meer und an der grenze der
ukraine
und so war für mich wirklich auch die
frage zu ob die alte bundesregierung in
den letzten jahren nicht zu wenig klar
und nicht konsequent genug war als wir
eigentlich schon lange erkennen mussten
und konnten das wladimir putin eine
demokratie zu einer autokratie umbaut
dass er nicht davor zurückschreckt
mutige stimmen für die freiheit mundtot
zu machen und seine machtansprüche immer
wieder eiskalt mit militärischen mitteln
durchsetzt diese aggression im inneren
und nach außen des kreml der letzten
jahren sie sind auch kein ausdruck von
stärke sondern sie stehen für eine
antwort der angst angst vor werten die
freiheit selbstbestimmung und demokratie
und ihrer strahlkraft
meine damen und herren
ich bin es auch wirklich leid immer
wieder von der ukraine krisen zu lesen
diese krise ist nicht von der ukraine
mit verursacht sie ist auch nicht von
der nato ausgelöst sondern sie ist das
ergebnis russische aggression es ist der
versuch
er versucht mit
militärpolitische einfluss wären über
die köpfe unserer mittel und
osteuropäischen partner hinweg
durchzusetzen eine solche haltung die
die rechte unserer freunde mit füßen
tritt und unsere gemeinsame europäische
friedensordnung zerstört der werden wir
uns gemeinsam entschieden
entgegenstellen und vor diesem
hintergrund wird unsere solidarität mit
der ukraine nur noch größer nehmen wir
die sorgen unserer mittel und
osteuropäischen partner nur umso ernster
daher ist es richtig die präsenz in
litauen zu verstärken und die
wirtschaftliche sicherheitspolitische
unterstützung für die ukraine weiter
auszubauen und frau ministerin ich
möchte ihnen auch danken dass sie in
dieser schwierigen lage nicht nur
beschlossen haben das deutsche personal
in der osze mission zu belassen sondern
dass sie jetzt sogar prüfen es zu
verstärken ich glaube dass es ein
wichtiges zeichen
ich danke ihnen und dem bundeskanzler
das sind all diese werte all diese
überzeugungen das internationale recht
mit klarheit verteidigt haben auf ihren
reisen die zurecht
und nicht in moskau begann und in so
vielen gesprächen und begegnungen mit
unseren verbündeten in europa und über
den atlantik hinweg mit ebenso großer
klarheit lässt die bundesregierung aber
auch keinen zweifel daran dass eine
weitere russische aggression und ein
erneuter militärischer angriff auf die
ukraine mit sehr harten wirtschaftlichen
und politischen sanktionen beantwortet
wird und dass dabei alles auf dem tisch
liegt ja auch nord stream 2 der kreml er
würde und müsste eine solche attacke
bitter bereut und
meine damen und herren diese drohungen
die steht nicht im raum um zu eskalieren
sondern sie steht im raum um die gefahr
abzuwenden und dafür zu sorgen dass die
konflikte und sie sind groß mit worten
und nicht mit waffen ausgetragen werden
unsere einigkeit und unsere
entschiedenheit das sind unsere größten
stärken in dieser auseinandersetzung und
einer der größten gefallen liegen wir
bleiben putin tun könnten wäre sie zu
zerreden und uns spalten zu lassen und
diesen gefallen dürfen wir ihn nicht tun
leider können wir noch keine echte
entspannung der lage beobachten die
situation sie bleibt brandgefährlich und
es ist jetzt an präsident putin
glaubwürdige belege für den
angekündigten truppenabzug zu liefern
leider lesen wir heute von anderen
hinweis aber wir nehmen auch sehr
aufmerksam war wenn er bei der
pressekonferenz mit bundeskanzler scholz
ankündigt über die antworten und
kooperationsangebote die die nato
gemacht hat für ein echtes mehr an
sicherheit für transparenz für
rüstungskontrolle
es sprechen zu wollen das gespräch dazu
es wird ganz sicher nicht von unserer
seite abreißen
meine damen und herren in russland leben
100 über 100 144 millionen menschen mit
denen wir in guter nachbarschaft leben
wollen zu ihnen gehören aber auch die
kritische journalistin die nachfragen
stellt um korruption aufdeckt der bürger
hat er bei unregelmäßigkeiten bei der
wahl auf die straße gehen der
mitarbeiter der renommierten
menschenrechtsorganisation memorial die
verboten wurde und wir wissen
langfristige sicherheit in europa kann
es nicht gegen sondern nur mit russland
geben aber auf der basis des
völkerrechts und der menschenrechte es
gebe so viele wichtige themen wie
klimaschutz
rüstungskontrolle globale gesundheit wo
wir eigentlich zusammenarbeiten könnten
und mussten so weit unserer hand zur
kooperation mit den menschen in russland
ausgestreckt ist so hart werden aber die
konsequenzen sein wenn präsident putin
unsere europäische friedensordnung
unsere freundinnen und freunde in der
ukraine angreift und andere staaten
bedroht das ist unsere klare
gemeinschaft gemeinsame botschaft über
den atlantik hinweg und aus der mitte
europas hinaus vielen dank
kein richter dieser stellvertretende
vorsitzende der fraktion bündnis 90 die
grünen mit ihren anmerkungen zum thema
erhaltung des westens zur politik
russlands
die zeit ist nämlich jetzt
abgelaufen ich frage trotzdem gibt es
noch ein anwesendes mitglied hier im
haus das noch nicht gewählt hat
das ist nicht der fall
dann schließe ich die wahlen und bitte
die schriftführerin und schriftführer
mit der auszählung zu beginnen das
ergebnis der wahlen wird ihnen dann
später bekannt gegeben
jetzt kommen wir zurück zur debatte
nächster redner für die fraktion die
linke linke dr gregor gysi
und gregory ist der außenpolitische
sprecher seiner fraktion der
linksfraktion
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen es ist immer die rede von der
gefahr des ersten heißen krieges nach
ende des kalten krieges in europa aber
das ist falsch den ersten heißen krieg
führte die nato gegen serbien und zwar
auch noch völkerrechtswidrig wir sind
uns aber einig das ist kein zweiter
heißen krieg in europa geben darf die
regierung verlässt sich gern auf
informationen der us geheimdienste ich
mich nicht ich erinnere daran der grund
für den irak krieg laut us
geheimdiensten und übrigens mit hilfe
auch noch das bnd bestand darin dass
irak und da es ihnen über
massenvernichtungswaffen verfügte später
wurden die hatten keine das heißt der
ganze krieg die ganze begründung war
unglaubwürdig und völkerrechtswidrig und
jetzt haben die usa
wie gesagt das bis gestern die
russischen truppen einmarschieren werden
in der ukraine
sie sind aber nicht einmarschiert ich
glaube mein misstrauen ist berechtigter
als ihr fester glaube an diese
geheimnisse sie werfen russland eine
völkerrechtsverletzungen durch die
aktion der krim vor das stimmt zu recht
deshalb gibt es ja auch die
tiefgreifende sanktionen gegen russland
nur die zwei von mir genannten krieger
einmal von der nato und einmal von einem
wichtigen mitglied der nato bahn
völkerrechtswidrig es gibt die
resolution
1244 vom 10 juni 1999 des
un-sicherheitsrates dass die gilt heute
noch und da steht drin dass das kosovo
eine hohe autonomie benötigt aber
bestandteil serbiens bleiben muss und
dann hat den hardware gesagt
interessiert und sie mir wir trennen das
kosovo ab das nato mitglied türkei hat
nicht nur seine truppen nahe der grenze
aufgestellt von syrien sondern es
völkerrechtswidrig einmarschiert
natürlich darf w natürlich darf b nicht
stehlen beinahe schon gestohlen hat aber
wie kommen sie darauf dass sich derart
moralisch meilenweit über bestellen darf
die nato ist nicht der moralische gott
gegenüber russland wegen einer
völkerrechts verletzung nachdem sie
selbst oder mitglieder der nato vorher
so oft schon das völkerrecht verletzt
hat
der westen muss bei völkerrechts noch
keine sanktionen fürchten russland schon
ein gewaltiger unterschied russland
fordert ein sicherheitsabstand in den
usa immer zugebilligt wird ich
wiederhole niemals würden den usa schwer
bewaffnete russische soldaten auf kuba
und in mexiko zu lassen warum billigen
sie putin keinen sicherheitsabstand zu
ich verstehe es nicht und putin steht
auch unter druck und wissen sie auch
weshalb von einem tag zum anderen wurden
27 millionen russen und russen beim
zerfall der sowjetunion zur
ausländerinnen und ausländer von einer
mehrheit wurden sie zu einer minderheit
und ihnen werden keine gleichen rechte
und keine chancengleichheit geht fängt
schon an bei der staatsbürgerschaft
viele haben kein wahlrecht und die
vorhergehende regierung hat nicht einmal
dafür gesorgt die diplomatischen andere
beziehungen zu nutzen um eine
chancengleichheit und gleichberechtigung
gerade für diese russinnen und russen
herzustellen das werfe ich ihr vor wie
den anderen westlichen regierungen aus
sie sagen russland denken in alten
kategorien von ein flusspferd aber es
war doch die nato die entgegen einem
versprechen von 1990 14 staaten in ost-
und mitteleuropa aufnahmen also die
eigene einfluss wäre deutlich erweiterte
die nato denkt in den alten block
kategorien der westen gegen russland und
china übrigens hat russland nach
herstellung der deutschen einheit über
100.000 soldaten aus deutschland
abgezogen die bundesregierung dagegen
hat immer mehr soldaten in andere länder
entsandt ich nenne beispiel 80 liter und
mali kosovo der us politologe john
mearsheimer sagt jetzt die nato hat mit
dem feuer gespielt und sich verbrannt
natürlich kann jedes land im rahmen
seiner souveränität selbst entscheiden
ob es mitglied der nato werden will oder
nicht aber die nato muss ja nicht jedes
land aufnehmen die cdu-forderung nach
geschlossenheit des westens ignoriert
die vorhandenen interessengegensätze
zwischen den usa und europa die usa und
weniger europäische staaten und auch die
grünen wollten ja nie aus dem 2 und man
darf die jetzige situation nicht
missbrauchen um dieses ziel auf anderem
wege zu erreichen
du willst
dass die usa ab dem 2 an gelten also wir
müssen weg von der konfrontation von
sanktionen von aufrüstung und escalation
wir brauchen das gegenteil und
europäische sicherheit gibt es bäder
ohne noch gegen russland
ingo wie sie der außenpolitische
sprecher der fraktion der partei die
linke im deutschen bundestag und sie
sehen im bundestagspräsidium hat es
einen wechsel gegeben jetzt ist katrin
göring eckardt vorsitzende die
bundestags-vizepräsidentin leitet diese
debatte und hat jetzt berichte
aufgerufen für aus der fdp-fraktion ist
mitglied im auswärtigen ausschuss
meine damen und herren liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen von der diktatur zur
freiheit sprich wieder zur sache
wir alle sind ja bestimmt sehr
erleichtert über die letzten
entwicklungen in der russland krise seit
dem besuch von unserem bundeskanzler
stolzen kiew moskau gibt es erste
zeichen der entspannung die krise ist
damit zwar noch lange nicht vorbei aber
die lage sieht doch weniger bedrohlich
aus als es noch vor wenigen tagen sich
zeigte der vorhergesagte einmarsch von
gestern hat gott sei dank nicht
stattgefunden das zeigt aber auch dass
unser kurs in der russland politik der
richtige war wir haben nämlich auf das
richtige verhältnis von diplomatie und
abschreckung gesetzt wir haben
gleichzeitig gesprächsbereitschaft und
herzlich gezeigt denn alle optionen
lagen und liegen auf dem tisch und was
am wichtigsten war wir haben gezeigt
dass wir als nato verbündete
zusammenstehen und uns nicht auseinander
treiben lassen denn das war ja das
hauptziel von putin
er wollte friedrich zwischen uns sehen
und sehen wie weiter damit kommt aber
wir haben ihm die grenzen aufgezeigt wir
haben deutlich gemacht dass seine
forderung nach angeblichen
sicherheitsgarantien nichts mit
sicherheit zu tun haben herr kollege
gysi sondern völlig aus der zeit
gefallene forderung nach einflusssphären
sind die mit unseren heutigen
regelbasierten weltordnung nicht
vereinbar sind putin wünscht sich
offenbar eine zeit zurück und
offensichtlich auch die ränder des
hauses in der es noch die sowjetunion
gab und man von
aus der sie den sowjet republiken die
politik diktieren konnte aber diese
zeiten sind vorbei herzlich willkommen
im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert es ist russland ein
ausschließlich russland das seine
eigenen sicherheits garantien gegenüber
der ukraine gebrochen hat im budapester
memorandum von 1994 hat sich russland
gegenüber der ukraine
völkerrechtlich verpflichtet die
souveränität und die grenzen der ukraine
zu achten mit der annexion der krim und
der intervention im donbass hat russland
genau diese verpflichtungen verletzt und
das völkerrecht gebrochen punktum
feierabend die ausführung von putin am
dienstag dazu er hätte ein völkermord
verhindern wollen sowie di donato damals
1 im kosovo sind hanebüchener
geschichtsvergessen sind
wir als freie demokraten sind
bundeskanzler stolz dankbar dass er
diesen protesten aussagen von putin
sofort und unmissverständlich
widersprochen hat meine damen und herren
international stehen wir als nato
verbündete zusammen und haben putin die
grenzen aufgezeigt diese einigkeit
besteht auch weitgehend innenpolitisch
nur am rechten und am linken rand dieses
hohen hauses gibt es ja bekanntlich ein
paar viele putin verstehe da sieht man
erneut in anträgen von fdp und linken
auch am platz verhalten heute die afg
hat keine ahnung von völkerrecht und die
linke möchte die schuld an der
russlandkrise der ukraine und der nato
zu weisen obwohl doch sonnenklar ist
dass russische truppen in der ukraine
stehen und nicht umgekehrt
mit der cdu csu besteht eigentlich
weitgehend einigkeit über die
russlandpolitik zumindestens mit den
fachleuten kollege hat zum beispiel ist
da immer sehr eindeutig aber ich habe
auch am dienstag den kollegen merz so
verstanden der immerhin partei und
fraktionsvorsitzender ist
dass die aussenpolitiker für die union
eigentlich keinen angriffspunkt für die
oppositionsarbeit sein weil die ampel da
sehr verantwortungsvoll agiert aber
dieser antrag den sie hier und heute
vorlegen ist offenbar von dieser aussage
ihres neuen chefs entstanden weil bis
auf den titel da sind wir uns ja einig
wird geschlossenheit des westens
entgegentreten gegen die politik
russlands haben wir ja genau gemacht
aber wenn sie der bundesregierung einen
gefährlichen schlingerkurs vorwerfen
dann verlassen sie selbst diese
geschlossenheit des westens und der nato
verfahrens offenbar selbst einen
schlingerkurs
scheinbar müssen sie sich auch hier
grundlegend in der opposition sortieren
und finden aber jetzt sei er unter neuer
führung schauen wir mal das wetter
schuld kurzum wir werden alle drei
anträge heute ablehnen die
russlandpolitik der ampel ist gut und
richtig und das haben die letzten tage
auch gezeigt viel
übrig
die fdp fraktion verteidigt natürlich
die ampel politik in sachen russland und
den herren den sie da oben auf der
besuchertribüne sehen mit der
offensichtlich gesponserten
atemschutzmaske das ist der botschaft
der ukraine in deutschland andere melnik
jetzt haben sie noch mal ein ganzer
schönheit gesehen jürgen hardt ist der
nächste am rednerpult sprecher für
auswärtig ist der unionsfraktion
derzeit nutzen den einen oder anderen
aspekt anzusprechen der vielleicht
dieser debatte noch nicht zu wort
gekommen ist ich fand es sehr
bemerkenswert wie der kollege rudi
lechte für die fdp
einen tiefen und windigen tunnel
gebildet hat um zu sagen um die fdp
unserem antrag nicht zustimmen kann ich
glaube sie hätten sich nichts vertan
dem antrag zuzustimmen denn er ist eine
gute bestandsaufnahme unserer aktuellen
situation mit russland und ein
wirklicher konstruktiver beitrag zur
auseinandersetzung und deswegen glaube
ich dass das ein ausgezeichneter anderes
in dieser debatte
väter bundeskanzler hat sich mit
wichtigen außenpolitischen terminen
entschuldigt ich möchte an dieser stelle
dennoch darauf hinweisen dass wir als
cdu csu bundestagsfraktion
unsere bundeskanzlerin immer dazu
gebracht haben dass sie vor wichtigen eu
gipfel vor wichtigen politischen
außenpolitischen entscheidungen hier vor
dem deutschen bundestag oder zumindest
vor dem europa ausschuss einen
entsprechenden bericht abgibt wir haben
uns damit keine freunde im kanzleramt
gemacht waren das natürlich immer
schwierig ist für die die termine
organisieren müssen aber wir haben es
immerhin gebracht und ich kann sie liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen von der
regierungskoalition nur ermutigen dass
auch bei ihrem kanzler einzuklagen wir
hätten diese woche mit sicherheit einen
zeitpunkt gefunden wurde der deutsche
bundeskanzler im bundestag über seine
russland würde die rechenschaft ablegt
ich hätte zum beispiel auch eine frage
zur nord stream das ist ja nun wirklich
in den augen vieler und zwar mittel
osteuropäischen partner total wichtig
der amerikanische präsident hatte in der
pressekonferenz mit olaf scholz in
washington gesagt wenn russland in der
ukraine einmarschiert werden wir das
beenden ich hätte den deutschen
bundeskanzler gerne gefragt war das ein
ergebnis des gesprächs wir olaf scholz
und ich die beiden standen ja dann hätte
er olaf scholz auch sagen können
und wir hätten wurst überstehen oder war
das wir bezogen auf amerika wir amerika
werden dass beenden dann würde das auf
einen dissenz hinweisen zwischen der
deutschen bundesregierung den deutschen
bundeskanzlerin an bekannten präsidenten
das hätte ich zum beispiel gerne gewußt
allein die frage bleibt jetzt
unbeantwortet jeder mag sich einen reim
darauf machen dann finde ich in dieser
debatte sehr bemerkenswert zweig wir
haben hier zwei gysi und bauland vereint
an der seite russlands gegen den rest
des hauses ich möchte darauf hinweisen
dass wir hier im deutschen bundestag in
der opposition einen eine diametral
unterschiedliche auffassung über die
richtige russland politik haben und dass
wir deshalb so wie es mein kollege war
früher auch dargelegt hat der deutschen
bundesregierung nur viel erfolg und viel
kraft wünschen in dieser schwierigen
zeit für uns alle diese kuh vom eis zu
holen und einen beitrag zur befriedung
der situation zu leisten dann möchte ich
die gelegenheit nutzen noch einmal auf
die wander legende einzugehen die hier
vielfach gerade von den sie eben wieder
vorgetragen wird es hätte eine zusage
gegenüber russland gegeben die nato
würde sich nicht nach osten weiter ich
bitte sie jetzt mal nur mit mir ein
kleines gedankenexperiment
halten sie es wirklich für plausibel
dass der generalsekretär der kp ds und
chef der sowjetunion und sein
außenminister im september 1990 die
vertreter des westens zur seite nimmt
und sagt aber
eins ist ja wohl klar wenn die
sowjetunion
auseinanderbricht oder an einzelne
ehemalige sowjet-republiken
unabhängig werden dann werdet ihr doch
verhindern dass der nato kommen ich
halte das für so absurd dass ein
generalsekretär der kp csu zu diesem
zeitpunkt überhaupt an die möglichkeit
gedacht hätte dass das eintreten können
deswegen glaube ich schlicht nicht dass
das überhaupt thema war es ging um aus
deutschland aber es geht eben nicht um
den restmittel aus der wikileaks hat
würden sie eine zwischenfrage zu lassen
aus der fraktion nein
ich möchte an diesem punkt weiter führen
und sagen warum soll denn der kpd jetzt
generalsekretär im november 1990 die
charta von paris
unterschreiben wo genau explizit die
freie bilden zwei drin steht warum soll
auch ein präsident bzw ministerpräsident
putin bei jeweiligen jahrestagen der
feierlichkeiten zur feierlichen
unterschreiben der charta von paris eben
genau dieses ergebnis gemeinsamer
europäischer frieden ich möchte darauf
nur antworten dass nicht bei meiner
position bleibe und dass ich immer
wieder
in diskussionen in der öffentlichkeit
mit diesem argument konfrontiert wird
und wenn ich dann sage bitte schickt mir
mal per e mail die belege dafür die
angeblichen videos die es gibt die
aussagen die es gibt ich bekomme keinen
eingang es bleibt eine wander legende
ein kurzes intermezzo zwischen
jugendlichen peter bis 3
dann ist jetzt nächster redner axel
schäfer aus der spd-fraktion mitglied im
ausschuss für die angelegenheiten der
europäischen union oder kurz
europa-ausschuss
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen
kollegen
das wichtigste an dem heutigen tag in
dieser debatte ist dass die sehr große
mehrheit in diesem hause sich einig ist
dass wir alles tun um den frieden in
europa zu erhalten dass wir das
partnerschaft sich tun natürlich mit der
ukraine natürlich auch mit russland und
dass wir das was der bundespräsident
auch am sonntag bei seiner wiederwahl in
unübersehbarer klarheit aus geführt hat
dass das von der großen mehrheit dieses
hauses hier geteilt wird liebe kollegen
können
und deshalb auch von meiner seite noch
mal den dank hier an den bundeskanzler
an die bundes außenministerin alle die
sich in den letzten tagen wochen monaten
immer wieder engagiert haben was nicht
ständig nur vor kameras sichtbar war und
kollege warte voll und kollege hat ich
finde das auch schon fair und wir haben
ja schon sehr lange auch miteinander zu
tun dass sie das ausdrücklich loben
deshalb verstehe ich auf der anderen
seite nicht die intention dieses antrags
wo es ja in der ersten zeile
letztendlich darum geht diese politik
wieder zu diskreditieren indem er von
schlingerkurs spricht obwohl wir uns
hier als spd als grüne und fdp gradlinig
und geschlossen verhalten haben
ich will aber ganz konkret darlegen um
was es bei solidarität mit der ukraine
geht der botschafter ist ja anwesend
meine stadt bochum hat seit 30 jahren
eine partnerschaft mit don jens
seit 30 jahren kämpfen wir dafür dass
mit medikamenten und anderen hilfen die
kinderklinik so versorgt wird dass die
überlebenschancen der ganz kleinen von
mittlerweile nur fünf prozent auf über
80 prozent gestiegen ist das ist
solidarität
partnerschaftlichkeit vor allen dingen
langjährige verlässlichkeit und es
blutet mir wirklich das herz zu sehen
wie es zurzeit fast unmöglich ist durch
die situation die russland zu
verantworten hat in den bass und auch
durch bürokratische schwierigkeiten in
kiew dass wir das nicht immer fortsetzen
können und die stange ausdrücklich der
organisation doktor lisa in moskau die
da behilflich ist dass die medikamente
die
überlebensnotwendigen medikamente auch
tatsächlich in bonn jetzt immer noch ein
stück ärmer
und was
und was russland anbelangt
es gibt nur frieden in europa mit
russland und es gibt auf der anderen
seite die notwendigkeit die wir als
westen das heißt konkret die europäische
union die nato wir als wichtiger teil
als deutsche jetzt gezeigt haben und
sagen wir das ja auch noch offen das ist
doch viel stärker jetzt als der große
westliche oder nato oder
innereuropäische konflikt zum beispiel
beim irak krieg gewesen ist das doch ein
wichtiger fortschritt und es war
übrigens damals gut
dass wir nicht gefolgt sind als deutsche
bundesregierung damals rot grün ums
beteiligt haben auch eine wichtige
erfahrung auf die wir heute noch einmal
hinweisen müssen denn geschichte hat
kurz mal gesagt und demokratie ist auch
eine frage des guten gedächtnisses und
was das jetzt in der praxis auch
bedeutet ich bin für das russland
monitoring in europa zuständig nein ich
vertrete deutschland die
sozialdemokratische fraktion einerseits
zusammen mit meiner kollegin regierung
reichen die die niederlande die
christdemokraten vertritt es sind ganz
eng beieinander im vorgehen wir werden
jetzt in kürze wieder in moskau sein und
wir werden dort mit natürlich der
regierung mit dem gerichtshof mit
oppositionsgruppen mit journalistinnen
und journalisten auch reden um darauf zu
beharren dass die dinge die russland
zugesagt haben auch umgesetzt wird was
menschenrechte was demokratie was an die
diskriminierung anbelangt da verstehen
wir auch dafür ist es wichtig dass wir
als deutsche in den europäischen
institutionen auch engagiert sind vieles
läuft dort parteiübergreifend das ist
unsere linie die linie des antrags der
cdu/csu können wir nicht mittragen
deshalb lehnen wir ihn ab vielen dank
zu seiner ersten rede an technik
kollegen schmidt das wort
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte damen und herren frau
präsidentin
beatrice kiewel
wollen die russen krieg das sind die
worte aus einen bekannten russischen
lied die antwort ist einfach sicher
nicht genauso wenig wie wir einen krieg
in europa wollen und was möchte die
union
in ihrem antrag spricht sie von einem
dialog mit russland
doch der inhalt offenbar das gegenteil
was sind dem antrag steht
wolkige propaganda nach dem motto böse
russen guter westen
russland wird die alleinige
verantwortung für die aktuellen
spannungen zugeschrieben und
steht ein russischer angriff bevor
erst dann sollte doch jeder schon einer
stattfinden aber
lieber nicht
tatsächlich hat sich der westen über
jahrzehnte
arrogant über russische
sicherheitsinteressen
hinweggesetzt der westen wollte nicht
einmal ernsthaft darüber sprechen ja nun
reagiert der russische bär gereizt
russland wird vorgeworfen die grenzen
anderer staaten mit zu missachten
das kann man so sehen auf der anderen
seite hat die nato mit deutscher
beteiligung
1999 serbien angegriffen sie erinnern
sich der erste angriffskrieg der nach
dem ende des zweiten weltkrieges von
deutschem boden ausging
die vor allem von rot grüner regierung
damals im kosovo-konflikt wurde mit dem
selbstbestimmungsrecht der völker
argumentiert doch bei der creme und in
dornbach gilt dieser grundsatz offenbar
nicht
doppelmoral wird hier zum markenzeichen
der union
die union stellt nord stream 2 in frage
und somit unsere sichere gas verbindung
gasversorgung
gegen die interessen der usa schwerer
als die des deutschen volkes
es wäre verantwortungslos waffen in
diese region zu schicken der politische
ansatz von cdu und csu wie das spricht
der nationalen und wirtschaftlichen
interessen unseres landes
[Applaus]
gute beziehungen zu russland sind für
den frieden und den wohlstand auf
unserem kontinent
unverzichtbar wir lehnen den antrag der
unionsfraktionen ab
kat jung ski wm
vielen dank
dadurch wird es ein leichtes
kopfschütteln gesehen weil botschafter
der ukraine in deutschland bei andere
wenig zu diesem beitrag offensichtlich
zu diesem beitrag von
eugen schmidt aus der reifen die
fraktion der in nächster redner in der
liste ist robin wagener kommt aus der
fraktion bündnis 90/die grünen und ist
gar sprecher für die angelegenheiten der
europäischen union
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
und liebe kolleginnen und kollegen auf
der linken
das ist doch eine groteske
außenpolitische fehlwahrnehmung was ich
bei ihnen immer wieder beobachten muss
wenn sie die ukraine und die nato für
die außenpolitischen aggression russland
und die truppen konzentration
verantwortlich machen wollen was glauben
sie eigentlich wie sie
ansprechpartner für fragen von die
kolonialisierung und antiimperialismus
sein können wenn sie so vollkommen blind
sind für die fortwährenden imperialen
aggressionen und fortwährenden
völkerrechtlichen verletzung russlands
und am schlimmsten und das wird in ihrem
antrag deutlich und das am schlimmsten
und gefährlichsten für den aufrichtigen
demokratischen diskurs hier im haus ihr
antrag formuliert gezielte
desinformation wenn sie schreiben dass
die ukraine über 100.000 soldaten und
schwere waffen an der frontlinie im don
was zusammen zieht es sind vielleicht
informationen die sie aus russia today
haben aber nicht aus dem monitoring
berichten der osze sie konstruieren den
vorwurf eines schwerwiegenden bruchs des
minsker abkommens denen es auf seiten
der ukraine in der form nicht gibt und
die frage nicht ob sie eigentlich wissen
und deutlich haben besten spielen sie
das spiel wenn sie das machen und das
zeigt wie wichtig die objektiven
beobachtung der osze vor ort sind und
welchen wichtigen beitrag die osze zur
friedenssicherung leistet und da
schließe ich mich ausdrücklich dem dank
der kollegen bürger an die
außenministerin an
und
liebe linke tun sie sich noch einen
weiteren gefallen überwinden sie endlich
ihre obsession mit der nato und er kennt
sie die tatsachen an 2014 gab es keine
nato mai dann in der ukraine ist ein
euro mehr an die menschen in der ukraine
sind auf die straße gegangen weil sie
für frieden freiheit und
rechtsstaatlichkeit eingetreten sind und
die orientierung richtige richtung eu
wollten das ist das was die menschen
wollten das ist das wogegen der kreml
seit 2014 mit voller härte vorgeht eine
integration der ukraine in die nato
steht überhaupt nicht auf der
tagesordnung im moment aber wenn die
voraussetzungen erfüllt sind und es ist
noch einen weg dahin aber wenn die
voraussetzungen erfüllt sind dann wird
eines tages der tag kommen an dem die
bürgerinnen und bürger der ukraine durch
ukrainische abgeordnete im europäischen
parlament vertreten sind und das ist und
bleibt das ziel dessen weg wir weiter
beschreiten wollen und die anderen
voraussetzungen arbeiten und darüber
dieses ziel und diesen weg wird nicht in
moskau entschieden sondern in kiew und
in brüssel und überall sonst in europa
und jetzt kommen wir zum antrag der
unionsfraktionen der antrag zeigt eine
starke euro atlantische allianz die
wichtig ist in diesen fragen und er
zeigt auch dass wir im wesentlichen
grundzügen eine große übereinstimmung in
diesem haus haben was die antwort auf
die russische aggression angeht aber
erstens die klarheit zu nord stream zwei
diesen antrag formulieren die hätten wir
uns vielleicht in der letzten
legislaturperiode auch schon mal
gewünscht und die hätten wir uns auch
von der früheren bundeskanzlerin
gewünscht dann wären manche diskussionen
vielleicht heute nicht so wie sie sind
und
zweitens
zweitens erwarte pool vielleicht
erkundigen sie sich auch mal in der
ukraine und bei ukrainischen militärs
wie dankbar wir dafür sind dass die
bundes außenministerin zu besuch im
militär krankenhaus war wie dankbar sie
dafür sind dass mit deutscher technik
und mit deutscher unterstützung immer
wieder verwundete soldaten behandelt
werden und dass wir ein neues
militärkrankenhaus ein mobiles dahin
liefern weil immer wieder auch heute
immer wieder ein krieg herrscht an der
in der ost ukraine und immer wieder
verwundete soldaten behandelt werden
müssen und das ist grotesk dass nicht
anzuerkennen und da bin ich der
außenministerin sehr dankbar dass sie
mit ihrem besuch in der ost ukraine da
ausdrücklich darauf aufmerksam gemacht
aber das hauptproblem des antrags das
ist ein problem was wir insgesamt im
diskurs haben in ihrem antrag wird die
zusammenarbeit mit der russischen
zivilgesellschaft erst an zehnter stelle
erwähnt wir reden über taktische
bataillone über haubitzen über
panzerverbände artilleriestellung
iskander-raketen blutkonserven und
solche dinge die aussenpolitische
aggression des kremls dies aber nur eine
facette der machtsicherung des apparats
im inland wird die repressions schraube
immer enger gegen die demokratische
zivilgesellschaft angezogen und auch
darauf müssen wir weiter trotz der
ablenkungen durch militärische
aggression weiter ein aufmerksamer blick
haben wir müssen den blick darauf werfen
wenn die individuelle repression
stattfindet durch mordanschläge durch
willkürliche haft und terroristen und da
ist alexej nawalny nur ein trauriges
prominentes beispiel wir müssen den
blick haben auf die strukturelle
repression wenn mit dem grotesken
vorwurf der ausländischen agenten
kennzeichen wichtige stimme und
organisationen auf dauer von der
bildfläche verschwinden sollen was sie
im moment besonders deutlich beim
memorial sehen wir müssen den blick
darauf richten wenn der kreml die
deutsche welle schließen lässt nicht
etwa wegen einer vermeintlichen
reaktionen auch dinge die wir hier tun
die schon medienrechtlich quatsch ist
als argumentation sondern weil jegliche
unabhängige berichterstattung in
russland unterdrückt werden soll wenn
man das feindbild über den westen
aufbauen will und die deutsche welle
werdet aber stört und wir müssen den
blick darauf richten und klar benennen
dass der kreml ein diktatorisches regime
in belarus unterstützt das 1061
politische gefangene zu verantworten hat
und kommende woche mit einem negativen
referendum eine pseudo verfassung ändern
will und gegen den willen der
bevölkerung die herrschaft zementieren
will liebe kolleginnen und kollegen der
truppenaufmarsch schafft eine diskurs
dominanz für den kreml die euro die
aggression richtet sich gegen die
europäische friedensordnung und
wesentlicher teil dieser friedensordnung
ist das friedliche zusammenleben der
völker diesen zivilgesellschaften den
müssen wir unsere aufmerksamkeit widmen
und sie und ihren einsatz müssen wir
unterstützen und damit eine neue
strategische widerstandsfähigkeit
und autokratie entwickelten vielen dank
[Applaus]
für die fdp-fraktion angreifen doch mal
kurz vor
[Applaus]
der präsidentin liebe kolleginnen
kollegen meine damen und herren wladimir
putin hat seine modernsten
raketensysteme und kampfflugzeuge
nach belarus verlegt die beiden staaten
führen dort derzeit das größte
gemeinsame manöver seit dem zerfall der
sowjetunion durch wir haben knapp 150
tausend russische soldaten die an der
ukrainischen grenze konzentriert wurden
wir haben panzer landungsboote im
schwarzen meer die auf ihren auftrag
warten 140 kriegsschiffe der russischen
föderation werden jetzt an ihren übungen
im östlichen mittelmeer und in der
nordsee und in anderen regionen antreten
das alles ist viel aber nicht
deeskalieren die situation ist sehr
ernst und sie müssen wir auch bad sowie
handeln und ich habe die hoffnung dass
wir hier zu einer geschlossenen position
kommen können wenn wir uns auch zwei
prämissen einige die erste frieden das
besser als krieg und die zweite ist
demokratie ist besser als diktatur und
wenn wir uns darauf einigen können dann
habe ich die hoffnung dass wir uns auch
darüber einig sind dass wir da nicht
neutral sein können dass wir nicht
neutral sein können wenn einer diktatur
ihrer benachbarten demokratie bekriegt
droht wir haben eine moralische
verpflichtung für den frieden in europa
für stabilität in europa und wir haben
auch eine moralische verpflichtung
demokratien in unserer region zu
unterstützen meine damen gern
in die lage ist leider ernst es ist auch
nicht neue jahr 2008 erlebt wie das
regime putin in georgien einmarschiert
ist wir haben 2014 erlebt wie das regime
gut die in die krim besetzt und einen
dauerhaften konflikt in der ost ukraine
provoziert und dann ist es natürlich
auch klar dass wir jetzt hier einen den
aggressor ernst nehmen müssen dass die
ukraine das tun das auch die baltischen
staaten unsere bündnispartner das tun
und dann haben wir als größte
volkswirtschaft im zentrum europas die
verantwortung das auch zu tun und
unseren beitrag zu leisten für frieden
und stabilität in europa und
wir haben dazu drei möglichkeiten wir
haben drei mittel die wir einsetzen
müssen zum ersten diplomatische mittel
um zu deeskalieren deswegen bin ich dem
bundeskanzler und auch der
bundesministerin sehr dankbar dass sie
diese mission in den letzten tagen
umgesetzt und ernst genommen haben und
ich denke da können wir als gesamtes den
beiden auch dankbar sein
wir haben als zweites eine
wirtschaftliche dimension die wir nutzen
müssen wir haben auf der einen seite die
möglichkeit die ukraine zu unterstützen
wer investiert dann in einem land das
permanent von krieg bedroht wird es ist
ja gerade das kalkül von putin hier eine
wirtschaftliche entwicklung und
wohlstand zu verhindern das müssen wir
tun und wir müssen aber auch gegenüber
russland klar machen dass wir die
sanktionen auch glauben dass wir
sanktionen benennen damit wir sie nicht
anwenden müssen weil es nicht zu einer
invasion kommt das ist das zweite mittel
und ein drittes kommt dazu ein vorreden
hatte schon erwähnt alle optionen müssen
auf dem tisch liegen das heißt auch wer
den frieden in europa bricht in dem er
einen krieg vom zaun bricht der zerstört
auch die grundlage für die
friedensordnung der zerstört auch die
grundlage für die nato russland
grundakten und das ist die anzahl
situation in der wir sind deswegen finde
ich es gut dass die unionsfraktion heute
diesem topf gesetzt hat ich bin
allerdings nicht ganz so glücklich mit
den anträgen die ich hier von union sehe
von der opposition sehe bei der
linkspartei bekommen wir viel folklore
und russland verständnis das ist nicht
ganz neu die allianz mit der ard ist ist
neu aber das andante beobachtung dass
sie den souveränität kleinere ländern
absprechen das ist auch nicht neu aber
das finde ich wirklich einfach
verantwortungslos was mich aber links
was mich allerdings wirklich überrascht
hat ist die ist ja unionsantrag die
überschrift des toll geschlossenheit des
westens sind wir alle beieinander aber
ihr mehrseitiger forderungskatalog ist
im wesentlichen eine auflistung der
versäumnisse die sie acht jahre lang in
der regierungsverantwortung aufgetürmt
haben versäumnisse sie acht jahre lang
seit der invasion auf der krim deswegen
lege ich ihnen sich mit ihrem eigenen
forderungskatalog zuerst zu beschäftigen
und seine ergebnisse mitzuteilen und
danach vielleicht diese regierung jedoch
keine 100 tage macht es zu kritisieren
vielen dank
die marcus faber war das der
verteidigungspolitische sprecher der
fdp-fraktion und nächste redner in
dieser debatte in der es um die haltung
des westens gegenüber russland geht wird
johannes huber sein der bis ende des
jahres mitglied der kfd war auch
mitglied der raf die fraktionen dann ist
er ausgetreten aus beidem und dazu
schreibt die agentur agence france press
von huber sind parteiinterne chat
verläufe auf den messenger-dienst
telegramm aufgetaucht in denen er
antisemitische verschwörung zu
erzählungen gefeuert jetzt ist er also
hier als fraktionsloser am mikrofon aber
putin muss anerkennen dass die
mitgliedstaaten nach 1997 dem bündnis
aus freier selbstbestimmung
beigetreten sind und der warschauer pakt
nicht mehr existiert wenn putin in
seinem vertragsentwürfen über
sicherheitsgarantien faktisch ein ende
der nato fordert und die stationierung
jeglicher ausländischer truppen in den
vierzehn mitgliedstaaten und das sagt
dann ist eine solche garantie
unrealistisch und nicht im deutschen
interesse
anders verhält es sich bei der forderung
eine weitere ausweitung der nato auf
georgien und die ukraine zu unterbinden
das ersuchen des ukrainischen
präsidenten sie denn zu den bis heute
anhaltenden bürgerkrieg in der ost
ukraine mit einem nato-beitritt zu lösen
muss das bündnis verbindlich absagen es
liegt weder im deutschen noch im
eurasischen interesse die nato als
konfliktpartei in den ukrainischen
bürgerkrieg mit anderen stellvertreter
konfliktparteien russland hineinzuziehen
das wäre die auslösung eines
flächenbrandes den viele bürger als
dritter weltkrieg befürchten angesichts
einer militärischen niederlage der
ukraine im falle einer russischen
invasion liegt es auch im ukrainischen
interesse am ennskai abkommen
festzuhalten und das normandie format
auszubauen
friedliche verhandlungen ohne
angelsächsische beteiligung haben 2015
die ukrainische armee vor einem
zusammenbruch gerettet wenn kiew heute
einen krieg verhindern und obendrauf die
vollständige kontrolle über die
staatsgrenze wieder erhalten möchte dann
muss sie lenski den punkt 9 aus dem
minsker abkommen umsetzen und mit den
vertretern der ob laster donetsk und
lohans regionale wahlen und eine
verfassungsreform abstimmen von dieser
entscheidung über dialog oder
konfrontation hängt ab ob ganz europa
das risiko eines flächenbrandes eingeht
oder nicht vielen dank
nina scheer spricht jetzt für die
spd-fraktion
und nina scheer ist sprecherin für
klimaschutz und energie und beim thema
energie und russland fällt uns natürlich
eine gewisse pipeline eine
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die situation an der
russisch-ukrainischen grenze ist eine
bedrohung für die sicherheit und den
frieden in europa insofern bin ich der
bundesregierung und insbesondere
bundeskanzler und nach shorts dankbar
für die ihn jetzt in den letzten tagen
erreichten zeichen der entspannung
dies zeigt dass es sich bewährt auf
diplomatie zu setzen und sich auch nicht
zu eskalierenden schritten an treiben zu
lassen und das sage ich auch
ausdrücklich in richtung cdu csu hervor
es ist nicht auszumalen wie sich die
lage entwickelt hätte wenn etwa dem ruf
nach waffenlieferungen nach gegeben
worden wäre
jenseits der akuten bedrohung und ich
betone jenseits wie sie von den
militärischen aufmärschen russlands
ausgeht wird es eine betrachtung
objektiver sicherheitsinteressen aller
beteiligter in den blick zu nehmen im
kontext völkerrechtlicher gegebenheiten
auch solcher denn natürlich solcher der
ukraine der eu der usa aber eben auch
auf russischer seite die bundeskanzler
olaf scholz im aufbau klargestellt hat
ist es unsere verdammte pflicht und
aufgabe verdammt gut aus dem protokoll
gestrichen aber ich fand den griff ich
den begriff unsere verdammte pflicht und
aufgabe unserer generation
dass krieg in europa ausgeschlossen wird
diese senden möchte ich aber auch noch
über eine weitere bedrohungslage
eingehen die innerhalb dieses aktuellen
konflikts bürger wird aber auch über den
konflikt hinausgeht es ist auch eine
sicherheitspolitische aufgabe die
weltweite abhängigkeit von fossilen
energieressourcen und dazu gehört
übrigens auch programm durch den
schnellstmöglichen umstieg auf
erneuerbare energien zu überwinden im
falle einer militärischen eskalation
könnte eben diese abhängigkeit zu einer
existenziellen gefahr durch energie
versorgungs nöte werden neben den
bekannten klima folgeschäden sind das
explodierenden energiepreise die die
heutigen preissprünge um ein vielfaches
dann übersteigen werden und werden dies
letztere wären dann eben auch die folge
knapp 55 prozent des in deutschland
verbrauchten gases
wären
knapp 55 prozent des in deutschland
verbrauchten erdgases kommen aus
russland
aber etwa auch die usa beziehen öl aus
russland neben aktuellen maßnahmen zur
vorhaltung gefüllte gasspeicher und
einer künftigen gewährleistung
entsprechend der füllstände ist es
richtig und wichtig eine strategische
reserve in staatlicher gewehr zu
schaffen den energieversorgung ist
daseinsvorsorge und darf weder zum
spekulationsobjekt noch zum erpressungs
instrument werden auch wenn russland zu
jenem zeitpunkt zu jedem zeitpunkt
selbst im kalten krieg geschlossene
lieferverträge eingehalten hat wir
müssen uns vor augen führen diese 55
prozent unserer abhängigkeit
können kurzfristig und kurzfristig ist
dort durchaus über jahres spannend zu
betrachten nicht ersetzt werden auch
nicht durch elektiven lieferungen
bereits die weltmarkt getriebene
energiepreisentwicklung führt aktuell zu
ökonomischen und sozialen härten auf die
auch reagiert wird wir mit heizkosten
zuschüssen und auch eine absenkung der
eeg umlage ist derzeit endprüfung die
maßnahmen verdeutlichen aber auch dass
sie nur für absolute ausnahmefälle und
zur abfederung geleistet werden können
um energiesicherheit zu gewährleisten
brauchen wir den beschleunigten und
systemischen umstieg auf erneuerbare
energien und zwar schnell verknüpft mit
speichern darunter auch passen ist ein
sicherheit die friedenspolitische
auftrag auch für einen continental für
einen kontinental europäischen verbund
übrigens dass die bezahlbarkeit von
energie nur durch erneuerbare energien
zu garantieren ist haben wir letztes
wochenende gesehen am sonntag wurden 95
prozent des strombedarfs über
erneuerbare energien gedeckt und das
wird auch an den bergen strompreisen
sich ausgewirkt waren billig wie noch
nie in frankreich übrigens nicht bei dem
atomstromanteil die dort zu verzeichnis
die am koalition hat sich diese
energiewende zum ziel gesetzt und
arbeitet unter hochdruck daran ich
schließe mit den worten friedenspolitik
ist auch eine energiewende politik
- spd fraktionssprecherin für
klimaschutz und energie war die
drittletzte rednerin in dieser debatte
zur haltung des westens zur politik
russland des liegen anträge aus der afg
aus der linksfraktion und der
unionsfraktion zugrunde und aus der
union kommt auch der nächste redner
reinhard brandl wird dass ein mitglied
im verteidigungsausschuss
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin verehrte kolleginnen
und kollegen zu zeiten des warschauer
pakt war die ukraine immer
wirtschaftlich stärker als ihr nachbar
polen nach dem zusammenbruch des
warschauer pakts ging für polen steil
nach oben sie haben ihre
wirtschaftskraft in der zeit fast
verzehnfacht werden sich die ukraine wo
auf einem niedrigen niveau langsam nach
oben entwickelt dieser vergleich zeigt
die wahre bedrohung von russland von
putins russland wenn die ukraine einen
ähnlichen weg nehmen würde wie polen in
genommen hat dann könnte er in seinem
land die geschichte der überlegenheit
des russischen systems nicht mehr weiter
erzählen und er will deswegen um jeden
preis die annäherung der ukraine an
europa verhindern aber das allein reicht
ihm nicht mit dem truppen auf zug den
wir im moment an der grenze zur ukraine
sehen will er vor allem die nato und
europa spalten das ist ein strategisches
ziel es geht nicht nur um die ukraine es
geht vor allem auch um uns und das muss
uns bewusst
mit der ankündigung mit der konkreten
ankündigung eines krieges will er uns
zwingen unsere eigenen werte zu verraten
und ihm das recht zuzugestehen über
andere länder zu bestimmen und zu
herrschen und er hat jetzt an der grenze
alles zusammen gezogen was er dafür
braucht und er wird damit spielen
monatelang jahre lang wir haben es doch
jetzt gerade in diesen tagen erlebt am
wochenende kündigte oder lässt er einen
aufmarsch für mittwoch planen erhöht
damit massiv den druck am mittwoch lässt
er den druck wieder raus in dem auch
kündigt truppen truppen zurückzuziehen
und er werde dieses spiel weiterspielen
und wenn er sieht dass wir unter diesem
druck auseinanderbrechen dann wird er
den druck erhöhen immer weiter nur wenn
er sieht dass wir das meer top nur
teurer für ihn dann wird der abriss und
deswegen ist die strategische und große
herausforderung für uns wie es auch in
unserem antrag formuliert dass wir den
druck entgegen wirken dass wir uns nicht
spalten lassen und im bündnis
entschlossen und geschlossen wirken
meine damen und herren ich finde es gut
ausdrücklich dass bundeskanzlerin scholz
in kiew in moskau und den russen in
washington wollen aber ich hätte es auch
sehr gut gefunden wenn er heute hier im
deutschen bundestag seine politik
erklärt hatte und die zweifel an der
geschlossenheit und entschlossenheit der
deutsche bündnistreue mit erklärte weil
es stehen natürlich fragen wie hält es
die neue bundesregierung mit den zwei
herzen liege der nato konnten sie haben
die anderen fragen noch im kopf
wahrscheinlich ich muss sie aber fallen
ob sie den zwischen praxen bis dahin zu
lassen möchten ich würde sie nicht zu
lassen und ihn bitten nahe die
kurzintervention zustimmen das ist jetzt
nicht in ihrem das kann herr bist und
bitten und ich kann überlegen ob ich zu
lassen oder nicht aber jetzt erstmal
sondern heute
ich war bei olaf scholz hätte nämlich
fragen klären müssen erledigt waren
klären soll die im raum stehen wie hält
es die bundesregierung mit dem zwei
prozent ziel der nato wie hält es die
aktuelle bundesregierung mit dem 2 wie
hält es die aktuelle bundesregierung mit
dem selbstverteidigungsrecht der ukraine
in dem er diesen fragen kontinuierlich
ausweiten
unversehrt er zweifel im bündnis und
nimmt die glaubwürdigkeit unseres
beitrags die unsere partner erwarten uns
erwarten natürlich von uns mehr als 5000
helfen jetzt war ich auch dafür um ein
konkretes beispiel zu nennen oder ich
war auch dagegen dass man der ukraine
helme dass nur der ukraine waffen
liefert aber dann hätte man es auch klar
benennen soll und nicht die
bundesverteidigungsministerium prüfen
prüfen lassen und dann zum ergebnis zu
kommen wir können gar nicht mehr liefern
das macht uns unglaubwürdig auch falsch
und schadet der bundeswehr und schadet
und bedient genau das narrativ der
fehlenden entschlossenheit und
glaubwürdigkeit deutschlands und meine
damen und herren der bundeskanzler hätte
heute auch die chance nutzen müssen um
sich von seinem unseligen amtsvorgänger
gerhard schröder hier zu distanzieren
er hat schröder wird aus russland
bezahlt er ist ein schwere belastung für
die diplomatie deutschland und ich würde
mir wünschen meine lieben kolleginnen
und kollegen von der sozialdemokratie
dass sie in den haushaltsverhandlungen
unseren antrag folge die mittel für das
büro von gerhard schröder hier in diesem
haus zu streichen
sie müssen sich umgehend keine sorgen
machen er bekommt genügend geld als muss
man er ist gut versorgt er braucht den
deutschen steuerzahler nicht für sie
wäre es aber eine chance haltung zu
zeigen und wir deutschland wäre es eine
chance für politische hygiene herzlichen
dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
das war der regelbeitrag von reinhard
brandl und jetzt schauen wir mal was
sonst an kurzinterventionen noch kommt
für die spd fraktion
keine kurze prävention mehr also jetzt
die erste rede von adis adrovic aus der
spd fraktion
sehr freundlich sehr geehrte frau
präsidentin meine damen und herren es
ist mir eine große ehre heute hier und
jetzt vor ihnen zu stehen und als junger
abgeordneter zur außen- und
sicherheitspolitik deutschland zu
sprechen das thema aber zu dem ich heute
meine erste rede halten darf ist ein
sehr besorgniserregend und sehr
bedrohlich ist die gefahr eines krieges
auf europäischem boden ist so groß wie
seit den 90er jahren nicht mehr mehrere
generationen in der eu und in weiten
teilen europas sind mit der abwesenheit
von krieg aufgewachsen
frieden ist für sie etwas
selbstverständliches auch wenn wir immer
wieder davon ausgehen mussten dass es zu
kriegerischen auseinandersetzung kommen
kann und das sehen wir gerade im
aktuellen wo keine konflikt diese immer
größer werdende gefahr eines
militärischen konflikt nehmen die
menschen unseres landes war täglich
bekommen wir viele zuschriften die
menschen fordern uns auf für stabilität
und frieden zu sorgen und das meine
damen und herren dürfen die menschen
auch zu recht erwarten eine liberale
demokratie so wie es die bundesrepublik
deutschland ist wie sie sie lebt und
auch ausfüllt
hat den auftrag unbeirrbar für frieden
und stabilität in europa zu sorgen
wir müssen jeden diplomatischen schritt
bis zum letzten ausreizen die türen für
die friedliche beendigung dieses
konfliktes bis zum schluss offen halten
ohne dass wir unsere werte aufgeben
keine seite
wird aus diesem konflikt als gewinner
hervorgehen deshalb wollen wir keinen
krieg sondern frieden mit diplomatie
auch wenn der weg der diplomatie oft
steinig ist und von einigen als zeichen
der schwäche nachgiebigkeit oder
nachsichtigkeit gegenüber russland
verstanden wird in diesem fall ist die
diplomatie der einzig richtige weg und
ein klares signal für mut und
entschlossenheit
ich bin davon überzeugt dass jeder hass
und jede form von gewalt ausgehend von
autokratien und diktaturen niemals aber
auch wirklich niemals stärker sein
werden als die kraft der demokratie und
das zusammenspiel aller demokratischer
staaten in europa
um es aber mit aller deutlichkeit zu
sagen damit hier keine missverständnisse
aufkommen sollte es durch russland eine
neue militärische aggression gegen die
ukraine geben die ihre territoriale
integrität und souveränität weiter
untergräbt muss russland mit harten
sanktionen und reaktionen rechnen
die wir gemeinsam und geschlossen
mit unseren verbündeten in europa und in
der nato umgehend verabschieden werden
und deshalb bin ich dankbar dass wir
über diese akute bedrohungslage heute
wieder im parlament sprechen und ich bin
mir sicher dass wir uns alle einig sind
was das ziel angeht wir wollen keinen
krieg
in der ukraine wir wollen frieden in
ganz europa anders aber als die
oppositionsparteien sagen wir als
regierungsfraktionen wir werden einen
anderen weg wir reagieren nicht mit
gegen aggressionen auf aggressionen oder
stehen uns partei stellen uns partei auf
die seite russlands wir kommen nämlich
nur dann einen schritt voran wenn wir
alle verhandlungspartner auf augenhöhe
begegnen und ich bin froh dass wir einen
kanzler die urlaubs scholz haben eine
außenministerin wie annalena baerbock in
den vergangenen tagen wochen einmal mehr
bewiesen was besonnenheit und ruhe
auswirken kann in der internationalen
politik dieser erfolg der letzten tage
ist ein erfolg von annalena baerbock und
von olaf scholz seine damen kann
und beide haben uns ganz klar gezeigt
dialog und diplomatie haben sie auf eine
neue positive qualität gesetzt und sie
haben auch noch gezeigt dass es aus
schöpfen das potenzial gibt
einhaltung und vollständige umsetzung
ist mit 12 abkommens
rüstungskontrolle zwischen der nato und
russland
vereinbarte kontinuierliche dialoge im
nato russland rat zu geben um an die
format und auch zivilgesellschaftliche
lösungen wie eine visa liberalisierung
für junge russinnen russen um den
austausch zwischen ost und west
voranzutreiben und was wir für die
zukunft brauchen und daran müssen wir in
den nächsten jahren aktiv und intensiv
arbeiten meine damen und herren ist eine
gemeinsame sicherheits struktur und
architektur bei der wir russland nicht
ausschließen meine damen und herren wenn
wir jetzt mit unseren diplomatischen
bemühungen scheitern wird die steigende
anspannung zu einem dominoeffekt führen
und zu einem brandbeschleuniger für
andere konflikte in europa wie zum
beispiel westbalkan und ergiebig schätze
sie eigentlich wenn aber fassungslos
über ihre ausführungen gewesen ich würde
sie gerne mal mit neben den westlichen
balkan ob kroatien montenegro bosnien
und lassen sie uns mal schauen was
zwischen 1991 99 passiert ist über
200.000 tote hatte der jugoslawienkrieg
ausgelöst und hätte man nicht agiert 99
wäre das eine fortsetzung des mannes
gewesen deshalb war das eine richtige
entscheidung das hat olaf scholz auch
klar gemacht in moskau zum schluss
richtig farbe co meine redezeit ist zu
ende
sowohl in der ukraine als auch in
montenegro oder in boston offener oder
anderswo in europa
wenn es zu grenzverschiebungen kommen
sollte werden wir das nicht hinnehmen
und deshalb lassen sie uns gemeinsam
vereint die stärke und strahlkraft
dieses parlamentes nutzen um den frieden
und die freiheit in europa zu
verteidigen es schlägt die stunde der
diplomatie von friedenspolitik vielen
dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
patricia riekel manager metro wird
pardon mit seiner ersten rede im
deutschen bundestag in der debatte in
der es um die haltung des westens zur
politik russlands ging
durch sie würde ich herzlich bitten zu
ihrem schutz und dem der anderen
dankeschön die maske richtig zu tragen
ich schließe die aussprache und wir
kommen zur abstimmung über den antrag
der fraktion der cdu/csu
aufdruck sache 692 mit dem titel
russlands politik mit der
geschlossenheit des westens
entgegentreten wer stimmt für diesen
antrag
das ist die cdu csu fraktion bestimmt
dagegen
das sind
alle übrigen fraktionen
er möchte sich enthalten
enthaltungen sehe ich keine herzlichen
dank damit ist dieser antrag abgelehnt
und leben halt mein anderen anträge die
hier diskutiert worden sind nämlich aus
der fdp-fraktion und aus der fraktion
die linke die werden überwiesen oder
sollen überwiesen werden beispielsweise
an den auswärtigen ausschuss und
das ist das verfahren dass jetzt gerade
im hintergrund passiert und dass katrin
göring eckardt die
bundestags-vizepräsidentin leitet so
dass wir schauen können auf die nächsten
tagesordnungspunkt das ist der top 8 in
dieser sitzungswoche vereinbarte debatte
das heißt alle fraktionen haben sich
darüber darauf verständigt diesen
tagesordnungspunkt zu setzen es gibt
auch keine vorlagen also keine anträge
dazu und es geht um den internationalen
frauentag am 8 märz traditionell wird
über diesen frauentag diskutiert in der
woche zuvor im parlament so also zu dem
zeitpunkt wo es möglich ist im parlament
dennoch im vorfeld zu diskutieren der
hintergrund ist klar die frauen
verdienen laut statistischem bundesamt
im schnitt rund 18 prozent weniger als
männer investieren seltener an der börse
heißt es und sind die hauptbetroffenen
von altersarmut ist also einiges nach
wie vor im wagen auf der anderen seite
so hat es ihm haben es die kollegen vom
handelsblatt dieser tage festgestellt
die im vergangenen jahr eingeführte
frauenquote für vorstände die zeigt
wirkung 42 prozent aller neubesetzungen
der top-positionen der dax konzerne im
vergangenen jahr waren weiblich der
frauenanteil im deutschen leitindex
stieg damit von 15,3 auf
19,1 prozent das sei so heißt es ein
rekordzuwachs auf der anderen seite noch
ein negativpunkt frauen profitieren
weniger von pandemie hilfspaketen als
männer also auch da sieht man wieder mit
der
geschlechtergerechtigkeit sind ist es
noch nicht so weit her wie es eigentlich
sein sollte und das wird zentrales thema
eben sein dieser debatte die jetzt
gleich beginnt erste rednerin wird sein
die bundesministerin für familie
senioren frauen und jugend eine spiegel
und jetzt schaut katrin göring eckardt
noch einmal auf die abgeordneten das ist
ja üblich im parlament dass es eine
kleine rotation gibt wenn das thema
wechselt also alle die sich hier
überwiegend mit außenpolitik
beschäftigen oder verteidigungspolitik
oder angelegenheiten der europäischen
union von verlassen jetzt einige das
plenum und es kommt in der tat immer ja
die die sich mit diesem themenfeld hier
beschäftigen interessant einige minister
da hubertus heil dem bundesarbeits und
sozialminister sehen wir auch gegen
bundesinnenministerium da und natürlich
jetzt am pult eine spiegel die
familienministerin
und herren abgeordnete sehr geehrte zu
hörende wir sind mit der plenardebatte
zum internationalen frauentag einerseits
früh dran denn er ist erst in 19 tagen
und das motto am 8 märz lautet
jede und jeder für gleichberechtigung
und da frage ich mich andererseits
natürlich warum wir so spät dran sind
warum frauen nach mehr als 100 jahren
frauentag noch immer nicht
gleichberechtigt und gleichgestellt sind
und warum wir vielmehr erst einen tag
vorher am 17 märz den equal pay day
haben mit dem wir weltweit darauf
aufmerksam machen dass frauen
2022 weltweit statistisch 65 tage
umsonst arbeiten müssen weil sie im
schnitt 19 prozent niedrigere
stundenlöhne haben als männer und in
deutschland stehen wir mit 18 prozent
nicht viel besser da und das
weltwirtschaftsforum hat vorgerechnet
dass wir gleichstellung erst in
135 jahren erreichen wenn wir mit diesem
tempo weitermachen und wir wollen nicht
so weitermachen frau ministerin möchten
sie eine zwischenfrage von frau von
storch zu lassen
ja
bitte sehr
[Applaus]
vielen herzlichen dank tatsächlich dass
sie die zwischenfrage zu lassen und sie
ist auch sehr kurz ich würde gerne von
ihnen wissen weil sie gerade gesagt
haben die gleichberechtigung der frauen
seien nicht erreicht welche
rechte haben frauen in deutschland nicht
die männer haben ganz konkret welches
recht haben wir nicht was die männer
haben nicht die gleichstellung die
gleichberechtigung
sehr geehrter abgeordnete ich bin ja
eben in meiner rede bereits darauf
eingegangen ich möchte das auch gerne
noch im weiteren verlauf meiner rede
weiter ausführen meines erachtens sollte
jede frau in der bundesrepublik das
recht haben auf gleiche bezahlung mit
den männern das heißt für gleiche arbeit
muss das gleiche bezahlung geben und
dieses recht ist nach wie vor in der
bundesrepublik nicht - und genau daran
müssen wir weiter arbeiten
und deshalb meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren abgeordnete und liebe zu
hören das sollten wir so nicht
weitermachen wir sollten nicht weit
unter unseren möglichkeiten bleiben denn
noch nie hatten wir eine besser
ausgebildete frauen generation als heute
gebildet qualifiziert und hoch motiviert
und wir sollten dafür sorgen dass diese
frauen generation sich genau so
einbringen kann wie die männer bleiben
wir
bleiben wir also als land nicht weiter
unseren ökonomischen unter unseren
kreativen und unter unseren politischen
möglichkeiten sondern schöpfen wir unser
potenzial aus jede und jeder nach talent
und zeit frauen und männer auf augenhöhe
egal ob mit oder ohne
migrationshintergrund
ob mit oder ohne behinderung das ist
mein verständnis von internationalität
und feminismus und das ist es auf den
punkt gebracht doch was
gleichberechtigung und gleichstellung
bedeuten und dazu gehört
dazu gehört selbstverständlich dass
frauen zur hälfte an allen relevanten
entscheidungen beteiligt werden und dass
sie genauso viel einkommen erzielen
können wie männer und darum bringen wir
mehr frauen in führungspositionen
darum werden wir das entgelt transparenz
gesetz überarbeiten und darum werden wir
auch familien unterstützen unbezahlte
arbeit im haushalt mit kindern und in
der pflege partnerschaftlich auf mehrere
schultern zu verteilen und darum werden
wir auch den kampf gegen armut von
frauen insbesondere gegen altersarmut
aufnehmen in dieser gesellschaft und
diese themen wollen wir auch in europa
setzen damit auf europa nicht unter
seinen möglichkeiten bleibt wir beenden
die blockade bei der führungsposition
richtlinie wir werden die lohn